[Laughter]
hey you guys it's friday it's birthday
it's tom's birthday yeah i had already
had a cake
well not a head
hole she rolls
[Laughter]
i had a good cake man good birthday cake
got it from publix bakery
it was uh they make the best they make
the best strawberry and peach
yeah what is it it's called strawberry
peach
sensation sensation or something i don't
remember what the pretty goodness
it's got like it's got kiwi and grapes
on it
fresh fruit on it
and it's got a uh the frosting is uh
just like basically whipped cream
yeah white whipped cream yeah so it's
not real sweet cake is with white and
there's a lot of fruit on it and there's
fruit in the middle too
yeah
so you can eat a lot of it you don't uh
you don't get sick of it like if it's a
butter and um uh butter and
[ __ ] icing sugar based
[ __ ] although i like grace too
but you can't eat a big hunk of it you
need a big hunk of it it gets too
[ __ ] sweet you can eat all this cake
you're like oh yeah yeah it's pretty
good
it is yeah
that was yeah um
i don't know because we always get cakes
from the publix bakery because there's
there's publix right there and their
cakes are all excellent like we've
gotten a lot a bunch of different kinds
over the years
but
the weird thing with the publix where we
used to live we always every birthday
you always wanted the one that was like
lemon and strawberry yeah store was gone
now but for some reason i don't know if
they still have it at our old publix but
they don't have it at this new one yeah
like they seem like they don't have as
many we've been playing we've plugged
the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] publix they owe
me some [ __ ]
they owe me free sponsored by publix
sponsored by publix seriously they don't
give me [ __ ]
except delicious cake i got you a
delicious cake
i know we had to pay for it though see
well yeah all this cake we're selling
let's see what everybody's doing yeah
and we went to momiji had a really nice
you had sushi and i had some steak and
shrimp hibachi it was delicious dj
maniacs in dom the bombs in there camp
guy glenn little
uh tammy's showed up she's a happy
birthday thank you thank you
uh danny rollyface is in there everybody
saying wishing me happy birthday thank
you very much
murder hornets singing about apple
bottom jeans that was a long time ago
dude have a
you need to start listening to some new
music
[Laughter]
um
so okay
all right we are um
we started eight minutes ago we're good
to go we're drinking
but probably drink light lightly well
that's i'm gonna have to drive
yeah we're planning on going to
mannequins like after the show
that's why we're that's why we're all
pretty yeah well you're all you're
yeah
i'm just a little bit prettier than
normal she's got you she's got a club
outfit off yeah i just i got corset on
too but it's not tightened yet i just
kind of like
sit down for a couple hours yeah because
it's kind of it's not too bad like but
if you sit for a long time like in it it
gets like kind of uncomfortable so when
i go to the club i don't sit i just
stand up the whole time yeah it's much
much better so
let's see what everybody's doing
veronica's in
thank you thank you everybody yeah
little pieces of cake you're all wishing
me happy birthday
oh my goodness yeah oh my goodness
yeah that's uh
basically that's all we did today going
on we just did your birthday thing today
no i'm not all flakka
murderhorn is saying tom's already on
flock i'm not on flop
i'd be dancing
he might fly
well now you're doing it
i'm not so poor where i gotta [ __ ] do
flakka
well you know yeah
i wouldn't want to do it anyway i mean
you know
even if i was really poor i'd be like
i've seen some videos of people i don't
know why you're gonna be like i wouldn't
spend a dime on that why would you want
to act like a
like a crazy one well i guess it's fun
for them like when they're on it
otherwise they wouldn't do it it's just
like
making yourself look like that for other
people you know but i guess they don't
really care i don't know if that's the
normal flock of high or if that's the
flock of overdose high
or or what yeah i don't know enough
about it maybe they maybe they're
getting dehydrated and their brains are
frying or something then they do that i
don't know yeah it could be that
millions of people do flock and actually
you never know
more or less normal
that might be a flock of overdose or
something
y'all the who don flocka you could drop
in the comment section tell us what's
wrong
what happens when when a person does
that is that the normal flock of high i
don't think it is
or you'd see it everywhere
yeah you'd think you think you just see
people like walking down the street like
doing the weird [ __ ] they got the
famous [ __ ]
famous what happened
what happened you know she jumped up and
ran
got the famous video of the dude [ __ ]
in the in the uh
parking lot freaking the [ __ ] out
uh and they're trying to hold him down
they got the black chick screaming
behind the camera go give him some milk
get him some milk
they uh
some [ __ ] meme master [ __ ]
lifted that [ __ ]
woman's voice go and give him some milk
and we're just like
anytime somebody gets [ __ ] up they
[ __ ]
mix in give him some milk
dude gets eaten by a shark and you hear
the voice give him some milk
just funny man [ __ ] love these dudes
wasn't that one wasn't that one like um
flocka wasn't the dude like kind of like
scooting like across the parking lot
doing a crab crawl yeah going what you
know you know like how the you know how
like how your dog like scoots across the
carpet sometimes
he's kind of doing that but
on the asphalt yeah and like so
everybody was kind of gathered around
like somebody was filming watching this
like they were just gathered there was
like dude yeah you are right he's just
like like his eyes bugging out like
scooter yeah i was like oh i [ __ ] out
i wonder if he saw that the next day i
was like oh man that was all in this
that was all in the floor to flock a
craze
that was during the time when the guy
ate the other dudes the two naked guys
in each other's faces
now see did they ever find any drugs on
that guy though he said no but i just
didn't know what to test for
you maybe not maybe it was like some
weird like exotic drugs it was flexible
i think it was flacco because i mean
there are some [ __ ] up people in the
world but there are very few people that
would just like eat someone else's face
just like in broad daylight like that
it's hot here in florida well across the
street from a [ __ ] hospital
in between a couple of concrete barriers
in between two
oncoming traffic
and the little barriers that they have
two bombs [ __ ] jump down in there
high on flock i guess they were bombs
stripped down naked started having sex
one then they started fighting and one
dude ate the other dude's face right in
front of the hospital
only in florida
and then they thought it was a damn
zombie outbreak and then the one guy who
was having his facing was like well hey
we were just having sex i thought you
liked me yeah
i don't know if they were having sex
they took the clothes off because it was
hot and then they started having sex i
don't know what happened
i love that one though i don't know what
happened
[Laughter]
like i said it's a hell of a drug well
yeah but i mean i think i've said this
before but you know i i'm not saying
that the florida man meme does that
there isn't something behind it but the
thing about it is that there's crazy
people in every state it's just that
florida has those sunshine laws where
like you get arrested for something it's
like public
you know everybody can look it up like
not every state has that oh they got a
youtube channel saying who got arrested
yeah here yeah sheriff will say to
everybody what you did and everything
yeah it's public record public [ __ ]
shame you i mean as long as you're not a
juvenile right like even though it's
like you know obviously but yeah if
you're an adult and you get arrested for
whatever um yeah it's public knowledge
you can just look it up online yeah so i
think that because all states don't have
that
then
obviously you know how most of the [ __ ]
that comes up is going to be like
florida i've like arizona i've heard
like they have a bunch of crazy [ __ ]
happening there too i think maybe they
have like the same kind of law if
anybody's from arizona they can let me
know that one sheriff um who who has the
uh
state puts him up there
to publicly shame everybody that gets
arrested for that week it's a good
channel like like it it gets it comes up
in my suggested feed sometimes i watch
it
on youtube
and uh he's just a
good old boy southern
baptist type
sheriff and he's he's funny because
he'll pull up a picture of some dude and
he goes here's oakley here's jonathan
jonathan got arrested for calling them
little girls on the telephone you know
that kind of [ __ ] like that meeting them
online
he said he wanted to get inside their
panties and it's funny you know the guys
he goes you know just like when he told
him that to their face
he said it online you know
yeah but they'll uh
you know they'll leave a lot of the uh a
lot of the details in he told her that
he had special feelings for her and that
he wanted to put his will up inside his
you know just real special they'll go
right in he goes right into it you know
what i mean and you'll hear
you hear people giggling
in the background
for some of the embarrassing [ __ ] that
these dudes get caught for it's
hilarious it's hilarious
it's very effective it's very southern
you could tell that you know it's like
some [ __ ] they would do in church
but it's crimes talk about it yeah it's
crimes that's serious you know thank you
aaron happy birthday tom thank you very
much for the 20 birthday thank you very
very getting my birthday presents it's
your birthday presents yeah pookie
brought him a birthday present earlier
today yeah it was a piece of leather
well thank you she
yeah she brings it i don't even need to
where did it come from i never saw it
was the leather strap that has a a snap
on it and it was to secure my charging
cable like
extra long deluxe charging she like she
had it in her mouth and she came up to
and she was like put it down and she's
like yeah pepper i was like thank you
it's like here i brought you that that's
for you yeah
she's so weird
but yeah i mean the thing about that
like as long as nobody got as long as
they're not making fun of the victims
and stuff i don't have a problem at all
with them like making fun of
well didn't they used to have i kind of
feel like i don't they probably still
have these but i kind of feel like on
fox or something like that they used to
have shows where like world's dumbest
criminals and all that kind of stuff
yeah well sometimes sometimes you know
it gets real he gets real serious
depending on you know depending on what
it is
yeah i don't i don't necessarily know if
i'd feel super comfortable like laughing
at somebody's like hey he murdered an
eight-year-old you know what i mean
that's not cool
and uh he'll be cast in all kinds of
dispersals he's a real high quality
human being this one you know he did
this and that and then
then he got and then we got him locked
up for life so you'll never see this
scumbag again
rots in hell that kind of [ __ ] so
they're that's a sheriff yeah you know
well you know can't blame him well who's
gonna defend the dude
yeah he got found guilty yeah man doing
[ __ ] you know yeah you did this you
don't have to worry about this piece of
garbage
throw the [ __ ] case filed in the back
okay the next one is you know just we
took care of that
you know
we took care of that one that that
dad did we took care of that
danny rowling says disco path yeah i'm
gonna do it i swear to god it's a disco
bad it's a it's a movie like a jail like
a neo giallo kind of movie slasher uh
can't wait for that review with that
being said what other giallo films are
you going to review jenny okay so this
month
i don't see you know it's not it's not
spoiling it i guess um
tomorrow i'm doing i'm doing a few like
neo giallo's like newer ones like um i'm
doing one called francesca that came out
in 2015. um doing one called strange
color of your body's tears from 2013 i
think it was which is like made they're
made to like look like old dials and
then i'm doing
uh dario argento's the cat and nine
tails because i haven't done that one
yet
i'm doing new york ripper which is uh
lucio folgi i probably now some of these
might change depending because you know
depending on whatever my mood is i might
do strip nude for your killer
i might do death walks on high heels and
or death walks at midnight i might do
case of the bloody iris and i might do
knife of ice but like i said don't hold
me to that because sometimes like when
the week comes i'm just kind of like oh
i'd rather do this one instead or
something else comes up you know what i
mean but those are the ones that i'm
planning on at the moment so
now you know
now murder hornet says uh like the guy
with the drugs that took it to the cops
to test it and see if it was real that
that that that vaguely
i think i vaguely remember that i
remember hearing about that yeah took it
to the cops to have it tested to see if
it was real
yeah
you know what that might have happened
more than once yeah i feel like
yeah they do [ __ ] like that
i mean some people aren't the aren't the
brightest bulbs on the tree let's let's
call it that
yeah then there were there was disney
apocalypse a few months back that's
where [ __ ] state police went after
[ __ ] disney and and got like 10
disney employees all of them pedos had
to have the evidence and everything
[ __ ] and they were publicly shaming
disney like these people around your
children you know
[ __ ] well the thing about it is
they're working at disney well
pedophiles
i mean that's kind of their whole thing
they will kind of gravitate toward jobs
like you know daycare or church you know
catholic church or whatever they want to
be somewhere that's like around kids
like that's what they do you know so
well so what's well i ain't going to get
into a disney i guess
they were catching them and letting them
go sending them back to whatever country
they came from too they they shamed them
about that they tried to grab one guy
who
molested that 12 year old girl in the in
the elevator she ran and told her
parents
and disney security got the guy and
instead of arresting him to send him
back to the country he came from because
he was foreign like i said that's like
that's like some catholic church kind of
[ __ ] church [ __ ] hey we'll just move him
somewhere else yeah
and florida state police wanted him they
got they had a warrant and everything
and [ __ ]
disney protected him they were mad about
that that's part of what why uh part of
why the state of florida started waging
war against
against uh disney
another thing that [ __ ] disney did
is they had some when they first signed
that [ __ ] agreement
uh with florida way back when disney was
new uh disney world was knew it was at
60s or 50s
they got disney world was
opened in 1972 72 71 sorry before it was
built is when they got the the the
permission to go do it they cut this
deal with the state of florida it gave
them basically vast powers the powers of
an independent state
they could have their own law
enforcement
they could have their own nuclear power
supply
ain't that some [ __ ] i didn't know that
they were going to build nuclear
reactors to run disney world they were
going to actually have remember epcot
center
yeah it's still there yeah
man that pales comparison to what they
had planned to do it was going to be a
privately owned city that you could live
in
yeah i remember hearing about how that
was kind of the plan but then it ended
up just being yeah it became an
amusement park yeah that's not what it
was the city of the future was kind of
like
it's kind of like a smart city idea
concept
um
you could buy a piece of property in
there
and be
in another country basically
a city-state inside inside the united
states boundaries it had its own courts
and everything
i don't know if it had criminal courts
but maybe it did i don't know but it was
gonna not that i remember but um yeah
but it was gonna have a nuclear power
plants cops
uh jobs
housing hospitals
airports it was gonna be and it was
gonna be huge it was going to be a city
but it was
run by disney weird when you think about
it it was going to be a parallel
civilization
with top of the line
state-of-the-art
um technology
for them for when they like like video
phones that's what they were conceiving
of you know
like televisions that you could talk to
each other through it'd be outdated by
today's by today's standards but back in
those days it was like amazing each
house had a microwave you know
each house had its own
[ __ ]
system it was like it's what it was like
it was like some other jetsons
yeah john smith says argento has a new
jello at the moment yes he does called
dark glasses it's not as crap as this
stuff has been for the last 20 years
well actually i'm glad to hear that
because i have been wanting to see that
but i've been very reluctant
uh
because i don't know man like the last
the last good move the last last good
dario original movie i saw i think
was maybe stendhall syndrome which one
was that 96
um
you know and then after that
i remember seeing uh the card player
when did that come out i can't remember
and that was uh
i don't even think i finished that one i
was just watching it going oh my god
this is so bad zach you need to bring
that [ __ ] strawberry lube
he likes strawberry
thank you dom the bomb happy birthday
time have a drink on me this is thank
you nate thank you very much
let me see them flash bulbs people let
me send fast bro thank you very much
i'll i'll drink that tonight at the club
yeah he definitely um
[Laughter]
no zach's [ __ ] with me because
earlier today
on messenger or on facebook
it was on facebook he wished me a happy
birthday and i said thank you i said
you're ready to give up some of that ass
and he's like yeah what kind of lube you
want me to bring
yeah i'm getting some ass from zach for
my birthday oh there you go yeah just
what you always wanted got his knee pads
with him and everything
flavored lubes
do you know what you know what that
reminded me of
that reminded me of i don't know if this
is still what it was like but back when
i was in in the late 90s mid to late 90s
when i was in the uk
in the train stations
and you know they have all those vending
machines it's like hey get some tea or
coffee or chocolate bars or whatever
and they had a condom machine yeah like
in the train stations and i swear to god
that well some of them are like flavored
so they had strawberry flavor and the
other flavor was guess what it was
curry
no
yeah it was a curry flavor i [ __ ] you
not it was a curry flavored condom
and i kind of won
yeah well whales i kind of wanted to get
it just because i thought it was so
funny that's ridiculous but i was just
kind of like
i don't know why strawberry is not weird
and curry is weird but i've never seen a
curry flavored condom before and i was
just kind of like i feel like america's
making the [ __ ] chili flavored
[ __ ] chili flavor i you know what it
would not shock me at all if they didn't
have some like chili
habanero yeah
i don't think that's a good idea and i'm
looking like dancing off the mother i'm
bigger than that [ __ ] now i'm thinking
bigger than him i'm just not [ __ ]
pumped right now i go in there and just
[ __ ] do some curls i think you see
i'm bigger than that [ __ ]
especially when i'm on a cycle but uh no
he was uh i'll we i like to uh [ __ ] with
dadzik make fun of him and [ __ ] but now
danzig was a great artist he could sing
and he could write good lyrics he uh his
show was [ __ ] on point back in the
day it's just
he's still good still real good it's
just hard to be a satanist in a world
full of [ __ ] atheists nowadays you
know
um yeah everyone's just like
[Laughter]
and no one's shocked anymore yeah i
don't know exactly what he did to
himself he's funny-looking now
and it's not age
i think he was taking hgh
his his head looks big something's wrong
with his face i don't know what happened
to him hgh i think so maybe well it
might be a combination i don't know i'm
speculating but it might be a
combination of like some kind of weird
hormone therapy and maybe plastic
surgery i've
gone wrong it doesn't look like any
plastics i mean i haven't seen him
lately so i can't really say space i'm
just talking about my face looks
slightly distorted and that's kind of
his face looks a little distorted and
that's that's kind of a sign of
improper usage as a [ __ ] hgh human
growth hormone that's what it looks like
john smith says it's still pretty crap
talking about the dario argento movie uh
just not as crap well you know that's
you gotta take what you can get nowadays
with daario he's old
uh though he has asia in it and doesn't
have her naked yeah that's odd his habit
of having her nude in his movies is a
bit odd yeah i always thought that was
really weird too and honestly
did i i think on flickers of feared like
let matt
last month or the month before i did uh
trauma
and that was the first movie that he had
done with asia and i think she was only
16 at the time and she played like an
anorexic because she was like really
really skinny and there was a scene in
particular where
like the guy like the protagonist is
like walking by the bathroom and she's
like um putting a thing like around her
boobs like to flatten them out because
she wanted to look like really skinny
and i was like
okay dad it's like i don't think i'd be
in a movie with my dad being the
director and like show him like my boobs
when i was 16 but you know it's italy
just they have a different thing i guess
and then in stendhall syndrome which
asia was also in she gets like very very
violently raped in that movie in like a
really really uncomfortable scene and
i'm just like i can't even imagine
what it must be like like on that set
it's so strange i don't think topless
means anything to europeans at that time
no it doesn't but it's just still i mean
it's still weird yeah to us it's weird i
don't like to them it doesn't really
seem to be weird yeah and the whole
thing of putting your
putting your daughter in there is a sex
symbol they had to fly with [ __ ]
old-school italians you know they were
just like oh yeah we're gonna make some
money oh yeah could be a star you know
you're gonna be a star well i just
thought ozzy was pretty hot it's just um
i don't remember
[ __ ] but she just uh it was just um i
think it was just a way of
making his daughter famous
i was like you had another daughter too
didn't he like uh fiore i don't know i
thought it was a building a lot of them
yeah a lot of european maniacs had
daughters like oh [ __ ] klaus
kitschy's daughter [ __ ] natasha i
[ __ ] always thought she was smoking
hot she is yeah turned out [ __ ]
colossal [ __ ] raping one of the other
daughters yeah evidently i don't know if
you can i mean allegedly i'm not really
sure but allegedly that's kind of that
yeah according to her
i don't know about natasha but he was
putting natasha in some of his in movies
too i don't think it was his own movies
it was other people's movies wouldn't it
she was in yeah and cat people i don't
think klaus cancer had anything to do
with cat people no that was her and um
uh malcolm mcdowell was in that i don't
remember who directed the the cat people
remake
because that's a remake that movie's
from the 19th
yeah well the original is good too if
you've never seen it like that's
probably my favorite horror movie from
the 1940s it's cat people
um john borman directed his daughter in
a rape scene also
yeah that's right
lou hernandez says i saw danzig back in
96 i think it said it was great yeah it
was i i saw it for i think it must been
96 also
when i saw it was for the uh maybe it
wasn't 96 no
thank you dermot
yeah thank you thanks dartmouth hey i'll
i'll be drinking that flashback i'll
drink that up tonight i'll drink that up
tonight don't get excited
i think he's like i'm gonna drink it all
i think i saw him in the uh how the gods
kill tour so that must have been i was
still in the army
so that must have been
93
something like that
and and it was it was great it was one
of the best shows ever saw
uh saw it at venus de milo
um in boston downtown boston right right
near [ __ ] fenway
fairway park
now it's called fenway yeah i think it
was over there near kenmore
but um i think it's what the name of
that stop was anyway uh they had
venus de milo and axis of those [ __ ]
clubs right there near the baseball
stadium saw him in there
[ __ ] show was [ __ ] mind-blowing i
was
i was right up front man the stage came
up to my chest and next to me were three
college girls from um college freshman
girls from japan they were in their
[ __ ]
1950s style bobby sock [ __ ] little
skirts and [ __ ] just like something by
the 1950s
because that's the way that that's what
japanese girls look like back then
teenagers they were just loving it and
we were getting crushed
from the pressure of everybody behind i
remember those and they were they were
laughing they were laughing you know the
girls i was like yeah all right yeah
yeah they could barely speak any english
i don't know how they got in but just
the way they were
i remember those days remember the mosh
pits and all that other kind of stuff
i heard many a day like back in back in
my day back in my day you'd go to the
shows and then like everybody would go
to denny's afterward and somebody's head
would be busted open and like you'd be
sitting there eating pancakes and like
somebody's bed was
opening actress
opening act was typo negative
yeah right that too open form is good
yeah typo negative is good too
they're a good band i don't usually like
that kind of usually like that gothic
metal thing but um it was better than a
lot of other [ __ ] that was surrounded by
that's true
that's true
again i have more appreciation for them
as i got older at the time i wasn't
really into it but you know
john smith said i think argento is the
same age as cronenberg some guys got it
some guys don't yeah i mean the thing
that's cool about cronenberg and you
know brandon cronenberg his son is also
doing his own weird ass [ __ ] which is
that's awesome
um
yeah i mean cronenberg's latest movie
crimes of the future is pretty [ __ ]
great and it's just you know it
it's just like a lot like you know his
old stuff
daario like i said he really
it's hit and miss like he did some good
[ __ ] in there but then he did like the
card player he did that um dracula thing
that he did oh my god that was awful i
think he watched that with me which one
dario argento's it was dracula right
yeah that wasn't that good did was that
the one that had the giant praying
mantis like the cgi praying mantis or
something oh that one yeah that one no i
don't remember i vaguely remember i
think it did happen that was like years
ago um i think shawna told us to watch
that she was like this is the most
batshit insane thing you've ever seen
and i was like okay i gotta watch it
john the bomb said that klaus kinsey was
a shitty father that's not the only
thing he was shitty that dude was a
shitty dude
he was crazy completely insane nobody
could work with him yeah
i wonder sometimes people like that
like he was a great actor and he's
always like entertaining to watch so
there's that i guess
but i always wonder like what's going on
in their heads though like how they
justify to themselves like acting that
way crazy
i guess you'd have to be yeah you'd have
to be yeah just because you're crazy
doesn't mean you can't be an actor
well yeah i'm not i'm not saying that be
crazy and be a surgeon you can be crazy
i know i'm just like wondering what goes
on in their heads though that fascinates
me like what's going like what's their
thought process total pure uh solipsism
and egoism yeah yeah totally everything
i'm gonna make this money i'm gonna make
this movie my own way
[ __ ] this director everyone is an
instruction yeah [ __ ] the script
[ __ ] all these other people you know
[ __ ] the story i'm gonna do it by the
way i'm klaus [ __ ] kinski
that's right
i'm king of the [ __ ] world i don't
need a script just you know
cut me loose and i'll i'll make a movie
with you you know that's the thinking
i decide how this movie was going to be
well he probably he probably thought to
himself well they wouldn't have hired me
if they didn't want my um expertise yeah
so which
i'm sure is probably how he thought of
it well you know to be honest they said
marlon brando's a bit like that
i had heard that so i don't think he's
as bad as klaus kinski but no but it
could have been guys like class kinsey
thought they were more than brando
yeah probably what it was because brando
could act he could [ __ ] act his ass
off he was great
yeah you know
well sometimes if you're really super
talented and there and you're always in
demand and nobody ever like slaps the
[ __ ] out of you right and tells you hey
you're not that great we can always get
somebody else that's almost as good and
we're not gonna cry about it so
their egos get like out of control and
they're just like well they just have to
put up with whatever [ __ ] i shovel
out just because you know because i'm
like the best or whatever
brando wasn't really like that though he
was just kind of a um
from from everything i've heard about
him he he wasn't really that much of a
prima dota either um it's just that
he was headed he was idiosyncratic
although if you put him on a project he
he he wouldn't phone it in he'd deliver
you know
he wasn't bullshitting but
klaus kinski
was kind of [ __ ]
you know he was they put him in movies
because he was weird and he could he
could do that yeah that's what he was
but that's what he was
just be klaus right
klozkinski could never be the godfather
he could never be court
seniority corleone can you imagine he
could never do that now i'm picturing
the godfather he yeah he could never
play colonel kurtz
yeah though
kinsey couldn't do that kind of [ __ ]
but you man you want crazy yeah that's
the dude you call it right you want
somebody that's like
peeking at you through your door you
know you're in your keyhole yeah looking
crawlspace yeah he was good in that he
could play a saddest or a [ __ ]
vampire
or some kind of serial killer he found
his nation yeah
uh yeah somebody's recommending the
documentary my best fiend yeah that is
actually really good
it's uh bernard herzog made it made it
yeah and it's about him and klaus kinski
they're a
volatile relationship let's call it that
yeah very very contentious relationship
but yeah there's more to werner herzog
though than there is klaus can't see i
think
furniture is kind of more along the
lines of
of of marlon brando you know he could
bring gravitas
well and he is actually not even known
for acting he's over directing you know
what i mean he's good in everything i've
seen him in yeah
it's like you're seeing somebody
important
you know
although klaus kind of does that but you
know he's crazy yeah you know
oh louis says brando was just lazy he
thought acting was beneath him he did it
for the money yeah yeah yeah
but he did do his job though yeah he did
do his job he did a great godfather
um did good in in [ __ ] colonel kurtz
um he was good in the wild one
um everything i've seen him in he was
good
but
the thing is is [ __ ] he spent a lot
he was high a lot of times
he he'd do weird [ __ ] and
that was probably true of a lot
especially in the 60s and 70s i would
imagine yeah it was probably really
difficult to get people to like show up
on set yeah you know like look at like
[ __ ] oliver reed and people like that
it's like they'd show up and they'd be
like smashed out of their minds yeah he
was kind of guy you'd find you know you
go to his house somewhere
and uh you'd find him living on the
floor
[ __ ] bean bags and [ __ ]
so you're here
and you get me a pizza
i haven't eaten in taste
yeah there's like dirty dishes and like
old like chinese food containers like on
the [ __ ] floor no one's taking the
garbage out or cleaning
i like i like pepperoni on my pizza do
you like pepperoni on your pizza
then get two
that's the kind of [ __ ]
that's how i'm imagining it
that's what i'm channeling
right
john smith says the famous quote is
about werner herzog and klaus kinski i
didn't love him i didn't hate him we
respected each other whilst plotting
each other's murders yeah yeah
it's yeah it is very interesting
danny rowling said sid and marty craft
had to be had to be high to come up with
hr puff and stuff yeah well i think like
i said everybody everybody was high back
then uh pretty much everybody the
monkeys
i mean everything like you see kids
shows yeah from the 60s and 70s sigmund
into sea monster i used to love that
though i love that i love that sea
monster definitely acid inspired oh big
time oh big time [ __ ] rip torn or is
it rip taylor rip taylor
isn't it
yeah the one with the with the confetti
oh yeah yeah he's just always like
throwing the game
it's funny yeah yeah
sorry i'm like
it's like i remember i remember rip
taylor but i i better remember like mst
like parodying him yeah you know right
but rip taylor was on sigma in the sea
monster remember he was yeah yeah well
he was on uh hollywood squares a lot too
yeah yeah he always had confidence
show up just be he's in a green outfit
like he was what was he a sea hag or a
sea witch or a c something and see
something he would come from now i kind
of want to watch that again i used to
love that when i was a kid and he would
use magic to fix some [ __ ] and [ __ ]
repair all the problems and then go back
underneath go back to the ocean it was
kind of like
a man where you bring this [ __ ] up to me
man it's just kind of sidetracked yeah
that's how it goes man yeah
[Laughter]
you couldn't get any gayer than that rip
taylor no way
no way trail no way
i mean can you think of anybody gayer
than that
was paul lindger
much gayer than kapolei much care
yeah he was he was taking it paul lynn
didn't have confetti yeah yeah yeah no
yeah in his pockets at all times exactly
zach if you've never seen rip taylor
[ __ ] on
just just go
you'll see him on youtube
just the old queen and just flaving
and he's the kind of [ __ ] that
would show up in a wig look dressed like
mod
or something you know you look like
yeah with like a turtle
some billy [ __ ] he'd [ __ ] have a
magic wand and throw some [ __ ]
glitter on you and [ __ ]
say something [ __ ] funny or slap you
you know what i mean and he had a big
old [ __ ] mustache he never must that
yet yeah he did have a big one yeah his
said i don't like rip taylor he's too
gay yeah yeah
that's pretty bad when you're two yeah
you see those like you can see them
pride parades as ridiculous as those
dudes
can get on those pride parades with some
of the weird [ __ ] that they're doing
that was nothing really you know what i
mean compared to rick taylor rip taylor
they're all copying rip taylor that's
what they're doing
they're trying to beat him well i mean
once they've rate once someone's raised
the bar that high just kind of like it's
kind of hard to like meet that standard
yeah
the the difference is this
okay um what was man i'm oh [ __ ] i'm
forgetting the names confused are you
all right do you have alzheimer's yeah i
got that all the time
he's got the alzheimer's did you talk
about the hollywood square what was the
other guy in hollywood square [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] great holland paulint okay
you can't compare paul into rip taylor
that's true there's no way um
paul lin was for he had a very intense
intelligence
um his his wit was [ __ ] super super
quick
he was [ __ ] funny
and uh
he's the kind of guy you could go to a
club with you know like i could go to
the club with [ __ ] paw with t and he
would just have like really really
snarky like yeah and i'd be laughing for
every single person but they'd be like
really really like intelligent they'd be
real [ __ ] good
and he'd be [ __ ] hilarious all right
you couldn't really do that
taylor would drive you [ __ ] crazy
he's like i kind of feel like he'd have
to be like the center of attention all
the time i mean
the confetti that kind of like gives it
away right the minute you like barge
into a room and start throwing confetti
around and yelling yeah that's yeah
that's the minute i'm just kind of like
nope
yeah
you get sick of him quick because i
don't mind like you know
i you know you know me i don't i'm not
real into like people that are like hey
pay attention to me yeah well that was
his stick yeah that was that was that
was his stick mostly that just like gets
up he was a comedian he was a comedian
yeah comedian and actor but i think
mostly just comedian and he he was on
sigma in the sea monster
we grew up with him and i was a little
kid and i said yeah yeah he's gay and he
couldn't even feel full little kid i
could tell i haven't seen taken to the
sea monster for such a long time
yeah all those like somebody talked
about the banana splits too like yeah
he had to be like on that [ __ ] ass
if you've been at splits i was thinking
this to myself the other day when i was
watching because i don't know if you
guys know if you go on the rifftrax
channel and sometimes like on 2b too
they not only do full-length movies they
also do
like educational shorts
and some of the educational shorts from
like the 50s 60s and 70s i'm like what
the [ __ ] were they smoking back then
making this it's like who was this made
for
like what
what even is this
it's just like the craze the ones from
the 70s are the craziest like they were
i saw the one the other day where
um they were trying to
i guess it was like trying to get kids
to make crafts out of like grass
you know what i mean and they were
making like masks and like [ __ ] it
was i was just kind of like what the
who made this and why would you make
this and
who paid for this and i was just kind of
like i didn't get it i didn't get it i
don't know who was watching it
i can imagine some like little kids like
me because i went to school in the 70s
i probably saw it when i was a kid
growing up and i'd be like what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] i don't know i'm not
there's i'm not enough to drive enough
trucks for this
camp guy says uh great liberace movie
behind the candelabra i've heard of that
but i've never seen it michael douglas
plays liberace and matt damon is his gay
lover
you know what i might need to see that
because i'd heard that was good actually
gene
got back to me and gave me sent me that
picture that was my one of my high
school girlfriends i said you got to see
a picture of your tattoo look at that
yeah oh right right yeah in high school
okay this wasn't it i showed her picture
before we were talking about the last
show
that was
that was jean she had a black widow
tattoo black widow spider tattooed on
the back of her shoulder
that was
1980
seven
well you have to think she was way ahead
of her time i mean yeah nowadays that's
not a big deal yeah it's like a high
school girl with that
goth high school girl i mean when i
first started getting tattoos in 1990 or
whatever it was
um i had tattoo artists tell me well why
do you want them on your arms yeah
because it's like everybody will see
because everybody will see them it's
like don't you want them somewhere real
like can cover them up or something i'm
like okay
because i think that was still in 1990
at least where i grew up in florida
there was still a perception that if you
had tattoos where people could see them
then that meant you were like
a [ __ ] or a druggie or something like
that i don't really know what they
thought
but yeah who cares what they thought we
do what we wanted to do anyway that's
what i mean i was just kind of like why
don't you just like i'm paying you so
why don't you just put it where i want
you to put it how about that you know
what i mean
i was oh i was looking up rip taylor and
the first thing that they said was
[ __ ] confetti
well yeah that's kind of like his thing
man rip taylor doing the confetti
yeah there's no there's no little clips
of him
see if i could try to get a picture of
it john smith says most messed up
educational film the abcs of sex
education for trainables
a film to teach the birds and bees to
intellectually handicap people in the
70s it's [ __ ] up
okay now i have to see it
is it on youtube
what's up i'm gonna watch it there's
rick taylor doing his [ __ ] you can't
really see thank you gadgy yeah happy
birthday tom thank you very much had a
curry and open the first stella of the
day i blame you guys yeah one of them
what curry it was it was a kirikan
were you here and brought that up
i totally did not make that up because i
was just kind of like i wish i'd taken a
picture of it actually but nobody had
cell phones back then because it was
like 1995 or something but i was just
kind of like curry condoms
strawberries fine but damn that's way
too far but yeah so is that on that's
got gotta be on youtube right
or something because i that with that
short that i was just talking about
abc's of sex education for trainables
i think i kind of have to see that
i don't know but maybe rifftrax will do
that too they've done some like
weird-ass [ __ ] but
they usually try to keep to
i don't want to say they usually try to
keep to like family-friendly stuff
because they don't so much um now that
they're not on a network anymore they
don't really have to
you know heat anything because some of
the movies they do like have nudity now
and stuff like that because i know when
they were doing mst
you know they were on comedy central and
then they were on sci-fi so it's like
they couldn't show like nudity or
swearing or anything like that so they
tried to keep things
pg-13
but
uh so i don't know if they would do
something like that but i am now kind of
curious to see it
the my favorite one and i think somebody
on here like recommended it but there
was one where these two kids and their
dad
toured the hormel meat factory it's like
half an hour long you know what i mean
and
man they show you everything like every
single step of the way like how they
make their meat products
and uh these kids are like ooh it's like
it's super funny
i don't know it's just something about
it like really [ __ ] amazed me
i think my favorite short that they ever
did
was
the one about i guess it was about like
dinner time manners and it came out like
in the 1950s and it was called a date
with your family
and it was very 1950s i think even um
hugh beaumont did the voice over like
the dad from leave it to beaver
and they were basically just kind of
like you know mom cooks everything and
everybody says grace and nobody talks
about anything controversial and it's
just kind of like and it was just like
so so funny it's just so [ __ ] funny i
don't know why i just i've seen it a
million times and it just makes me laugh
every single time
and let's see do do do camp guys said
tom needs to see the youtube video
tallulah gorge kayaking one of the
better videos by channel named christian
hayden
called 500 cfs some of the most
beautiful scenery in the world was super
killer white water
uh zach says an american condom would be
ghost pepper flavored probably you know
somebody made one you know somebody's
made one just like for a novelty like
for a gag gift or something like that
you know what i mean i don't really
understand
why like why would you even need a
flavored condom
you know
it's just to me
i don't know like i said it just seems
like a gag most of the time because it's
like what the fella what the [ __ ] are
they like using the flavoring and it's
just kind of like
if you're putting the flavoring on the
condom it's just like is that gonna like
react badly it might have have an
allergic reaction to that [ __ ] it's like
in a very uncomfortable place i don't i
don't really like the feeling i don't
like that
um louis says i went to high school with
lots of dudes with tattoos yeah i mean
the weird thing about it maybe it was
just here i don't think i knew anybody
with tattoos
until
later i mean it was just kind of like
like i said i started getting mine i
think in 1990 or 1991
and high school girls didn't have didn't
i didn't know anybody that had any like
in high school it just wasn't something
that people did but i feel like after
like 1991
when you know grunge came in like punk
got big and everything like that then
everyone was doing it yeah
thank you sly
thanks lot
i'm gonna drink that up tonight
i mean don't drink it all i'm just
making save some of it flashbulb
john smith said it's on youtube okay i'm
gonna have to if i remember i'm gonna
like watch that it's well meant but
seems to be social workers terrifying
people oh my god i watched one that they
did on rifftrax the other day that was
called i think it's just called setting
up a room and it's obviously geared
toward
teachers like elementary school teachers
kindergarten teachers probably
and like how to set up your classroom
but the the thing about it it's like an
older teacher and i'm assuming like her
younger assistant and it's like half an
hour
of them just like wandering around this
big room and like arranging things and
i'm just kind of like
it's like mind numbing
and it's weird too because this was back
i don't know when it was made it was the
70s sometime i'm assuming it was early
70s
and
they didn't have like it is the brownest
like wood grain room
for a kindergarten that i've ever seen
there's like nothing on the walls
there's all the blocks are just like
plain wood none of them are painted or
colorful or anything like that like
there's like little
kitchen sets like for them to like
figure out there's a little bedroom and
a little cradle and a little kitchen
where you can
pretend you're cooking and [ __ ] like
that but not all of it is like made of
wood or it's all like beige
like nothing is colorful like nowadays
you'd see toys and they'd be like super
colorful
but
i just thought it was very very weird
i'm like oh my god everything is i know
the 70s was all very natural and
everything like that but i was just like
holy crap that
room just looks like the most depressing
[ __ ] ever there's like no color in there
at all oh my god
zach says uh one of my favorite what
youtube channels is the tri channel oh
i've heard of that yeah
random irish people
trying various things mostly food and
booze and it's hilarious
i don't know there's just something
really fascinating about channels where
people who don't usually eat or drink
whatever the thing is
like eating or drinking that thing oh
grandparents here hey graham i just
showed an old picture of uh
gene gene petrowski remember her with
their [ __ ] little spider tattoo i
showed it
because i mean yeah that was only girl
in high school i had a tattoo
well that you knew of maybe some had
some and it was like secret yeah maybe
they i kind of feel like they were maybe
more stringent back then about you had
to be 18.
maybe
i don't know at least where i was
because i think it was like a big deal
like wait till you were 18.
but don't i keep getting recommended
those videos too it's like hey people
from some like remote
video somewhere like have cheesecake for
the first time you know what i mean
remember her
he remembers
yeah grandpa said we had fake ids and
trenton 17 year olds had no problem
getting beer and tats yeah
[Laughter]
they weren't strict on it i guess it
wasn't a thing nobody was complaining
yeah i mean i think
when i got my first one
um
which has been actually this it's not
this one because that's
my first one has been covered up by this
but i liked it but it just like bled you
know what i mean because it was old
but i think i was 19 when i got my first
one
because i waited until i was out of high
school
so you know plus it took me a long time
to like decide what i wanted i actually
wouldn't mind having more but
they're i can't they're just so
expensive man
i wanted a whole back piece actually but
i can't afford that [ __ ]
that's gonna be like a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton
of money if i win the lottery i'll get
one
i even know what i want but it's taking
no there's no way i'm paying for it
she got that taylor
grantha said she got that in taylor
those shops tattooed anyone who walked
through the door yeah probably try it
probably right
taylor michigan
zach says oh they just uploaded a video
of them trying werther's originals
the irish guy the try guys or they're
not try guys that's a different channel
but like yeah he's talking about um
irish guys
the tri channel yeah all right so we got
a pretty good uh man where those
originals are we got how long we've been
streaming now about an hour probably
almost all right so we're warmed up we
got um
decent crowd in there 35 people which is
good for our live shows because nobody
watches our live [ __ ] they watch us
[ __ ] recording all right because yeah
we're trying we usually get people
through the workday
but uh
is there anything you guys want to talk
about if you have any topics you want to
get on to be [ __ ] unsolved mysteries
or paranormal or any crime case that we
covered in the past or anything you want
to talk about in the future go ahead and
drop it down in the comment section me
and jenny will address it
in the meantime we're just gonna sit
here and uh
drink some of this up i gotta watch what
i drink
today
because uh i gotta drive to the bar
i mean that's one second at the bar i
got drinks i mean that's not for a
couple hours we're not leaving until
like nine so don't be alarmed okay you
know what i mean so we might like stop
before yeah because it's not even seven
we're not leaving until nine o'clock so
it'll be like a few hours so zach did
they like the werther's original i mean
i can't imagine anybody wouldn't like
werther's originals because they're
delicious but i know it's old people
candy but they're still good so [ __ ] it
um
let me see oh i got my first uh john
smith says i got my first tattoo at 17
had it removed at 31 because what's cool
at 17 looks shite at 31 yeah exactly
that's kind of what i was thinking of
when i was 19. i was like well i don't
want something that like looks crappy
and i honestly like the the tattoo that
i had covered up my first one i didn't
hate it i would have had it done again
but it's just it was so old and it was
like really really thick black lines it
was like a i it was like an owl it was
like kind of a
um stylized like an owl
and i really liked it but it started to
like bleed out and fade and stuff like
that so i said well i'll just have it
covered up because then we knew a tattoo
artist and we wanted to do something
um said it was the albanian eagle on my
chest took it off because people thought
it was a nazi
yeah i could see that i could see that
um
let's see
zach says i re-watched jaws
although he called it jews
i bet he went there john
somebody made like a jaws parody that's
called juice
like jewish people like [ __ ] oh my
god that would be super funny uh he saw
how yummy young richard dreyfuss was can
we talk about that he was actually
pretty cute back in his day
i feel like
like if you're into kind of like he i
mean he was real
he was kind of like the intellectual
type and he was kind of like
you know
but you know i can see it
somebody asked when i thought of the
[ __ ] horse tread in the field at the
end of the day i don't watch horse
racing
you know what's weird when we were at
momiji today there was a hor i think it
was the breeders cup was it was on but
then well there were two tvs on over the
bar and i think one that was i think it
was the breeders cup but then the other
tv had uh
what was that what's that show with the
guy fieri called
dr uh
diners drive-ins and dives or whatever i
actually kind of like that too guy
fieri's annoying as [ __ ] but that's a
fun show though
danny rowling said uh spiderweb tattoos
are douchey
i mean they can be yeah
they can't be yet
uh zach said i was asking tom about this
earlier what's your thoughts on the
johnny depp trial i didn't watch it i
didn't either i didn't i didn't care
like i said i don't really like care
about celebrity [ __ ] i was saying the
same so i don't really that's what i
told zach he asked me about it and i was
just like uh i i have um i have no
interest
in um
those old school celebrities most of
them there's a few of them yeah i think
i might be like crusoe might be
interested you know but most of those
people
they're just people working you know
all i gotta do is just look at their
marriages
they get married and then they [ __ ]
turns out that they just white trash and
[ __ ] fighting and then they break up
again and [ __ ] amber heard taking a
[ __ ]
taking squeezing out turds on the bed
and [ __ ] people are [ __ ] crazy man
they're just
i think what happens is those
celebrities will marry each other and
then a lot of times they've they once
they get to know
who they are they're like oh this is
just another [ __ ] it's just a regular
person yeah and then like what did you
think yeah well see i think that a lot
of people have that misperception about
celebrities it's like because they
always look really good all the time and
blah blah i'm like yeah they look really
good because they're rich and they have
like a whole bunch of people doing their
makeup and hair and
dressing them and [ __ ] like that yeah
it's like you know if you left them to
their own devices they'd probably go
around looking like the rest of us you
know those people don't really come from
anything
you know what would they be doing if
they weren't that they'd you know be
working at a grocery store somewhere the
girls would be hookers you know
something like that you know the um
that's why that's how
old weinstein had so much power over him
because he could uh
he could hand out millions of dollars
jobs worth millions and millions of
dollars to these women so he could do
whatever he wanted to him and he could
make them do things like go [ __ ] that
dude or you won't get the [ __ ] part
and that part represented [ __ ] 10
million dollars this is somebody that
really would have been working at
walgreens
if they weren't in hollywood
so they had to do it
so i
they they get married and then they get
the guess they kind of get disenchanted
with each other because they just and
it's not just talking about those two i
think it's just in general they get
disenchanted a lot of times because
they're just
regular slubs
yeah it's like like i said they're not
special i mean you know they're special
because they got money but that's about
it there's that a lot of that's just
kind of luck some of it's talent too but
you know right place right time yeah i
mean the thing is it doesn't take that
much talent to pull that off
and they can get all the help they want
you know
to execute something you know in terms
you know you can get cg to touch up your
[ __ ] love handles they can change
what color your face is and de-age you
but yeah nowadays it's like you don't
have to worry about it
i think what happened
what was funny is that i had never seen
johnny depp off screen i only seen him
on screen
so i had no idea what he was like
i think i saw him on a couple talk shows
had a guest but you could tell he's
still working you know what i mean he's
the character johnny depp it's a
character
he tried to live stream one time when
these accusations came down it's the
first time i saw him when he wasn't on a
movie he was trying to live stream to
people i think he was
i
i saw a recording of the live stream on
youtube
i didn't see the actual live stream it's
probably about two days old
and he looked very uncomfortable
he couldn't really be himself just
talking to people and i was looking at
this guy i was going this is just this i
felt bad for him you know
it was like this guy when he's off when
he doesn't have a script in his hand he
doesn't really know how to act or to
talk to anybody
which made me think he's kind of a
kind of a guy disconnected from average
people i don't you know well we were
kind of talking about this when we were
talking about tom cruise because it's
like once you're that famous and
recognizable and once you're that rich
you don't really have to
interact with regular people to any
great extent anymore yeah so i feel like
you kind of forget how yeah because
you're kind of like isolated from that i
could feel
i'm pretty good when it comes to reading
body language and getting kind of
empathy from people
he's trying to come across
as a regular guy but he can't drop
the johnny depp act he doesn't really
know what to do
you know i mean should i be myself or
should i be johnny depp the the the
corporate johnny depp that
and he's kind of stuck a little bit in
the middle
and um
i just kind of had the feeling there's
not there wasn't a lot of
original personality that he cared to
show
you know what i mean
he couldn't really show himself although
he's
being on that trial might have been good
for him
because i think i caught little clips of
it he was his his body language was
natural he was moving naturally
it could be that reality tv or being an
or the trial acted kind of like being on
a reality show
which maybe gave him a little bit more
confidence to be himself in public
you know
because he'd never done a that's what me
and jenny do it basically for a living
doing these live streams you're being
yourself in public he'd never had to do
that
you know and graham me and graham he's
in the con
we came up through the same little drama
club together we had a good drama
teacher and [ __ ] you know i was doing
leads and musicals and stuff it is a
skill you have to learn
to put on a performance it's very
different
from
a live stream i i really prefer a live
stream to do it a performance
you know
although these get old too because i'm
like oh i got to do it again but then
once i start rolling i'm like yeah yeah
back on yeah i mean i find these
actually like pretty fun like hanging
out with you guys um probably the friday
night ones more than the i think that
wednesday night ones are fun but it's
like i'm always kind of like worried
about how like this like the one we did
wednesday it's like ended up being five
hours long because
we kept getting like sidetracked off of
like all my notes and i'm always kind of
like worried that like oh i'm not going
to cover everything i wanted to cover
blah blah and then like friday i don't
have to worry about that but the thing
about it is that
i don't i was never like uh you know the
i was never um wanted to be like an
actor like drama and stuff never
appealed to me just because i don't i'm
not comfortable like pretending to be
somebody else or pretending to be like
like i'm not you know what i mean it's
not like a lot of people imagine but
i've just never been comfortable like
that so it's just kind of like
to me it's like if i'm gonna be on here
like talking and [ __ ] like that i don't
really
know how to be any other way other than
what i'm actually like i mean you know
he knows i'm here i'm like this all the
time yeah this is what i'm like all the
time yeah
but acting is very different than this
it's a lot different
it's a lot different than what people
think it is um graham will tell you
the traditional way of doing it always
usually involves things like you got to
do a bunch of stretches and calisthenics
and you have to [ __ ] do dance moves
in front of
people and understand blocking and you
have to get over your fear of
[ __ ] making certain facial
expressions and reaching out projecting
to a [ __ ] crowd of people that are
watching you
you know there's kind of like uh
instinctively people are kind of have
inhibitions about raising their hands
above their
shoulder level in front of a huge crowd
of people there's things you have to
kind of
beat out of you through
repetitions and
it's almost like calisthenics
and then we did some of that when i was
in like uh choruses and stuff as well
like i did that too and then they start
incorporating
dance and singing and then you got to
learn about certain kind of methods of
acting that have happened in the past
and then blocking and which is how to
move on a stage and how to set stages up
and that's just the very foundations and
then it starts getting later on into
film how film is done
and we used to we had video production
too um which i have like a couple of
those remember we did that black box
stuff
and um
it's an interesting
science or skill
it's good that you have to have those
foundations
but there was nothing about
live streaming all right the closest
thing
they ever had to something like that
would be vaudeville and even that was
real stage stagey um so there's nothing
in theater that's like live streaming
the show
except maybe
even early live tv wasn't like this
because that was all scripted and it was
[ __ ] bunches of people the closest
thing to this would be a radio show
like what they call a morning zoo like
howard storm however howard stern show
is kind of like a morning zoo which is a
bunch of people [ __ ] hanging out put
but even those were pretty scripted
you know yeah and they actually had
yeah i mean now the commercials and
there were segments involved there were
schedules everything was scheduled out
[ __ ] months in advance yes guests
they're not as
natural as they sounded
you know this is very natural compared
to all that yeah i mean like i said when
we do the wednesday shows i obviously we
obviously have a topic and i obviously
have like notes that i'm referring to
like about the topic so i can refer to
things but friday
we have no idea we don't talk about oh
what are we going to talk about friday
night we don't we just like turn the
[ __ ] on and be like well we'll just
we'll see what happens yeah
it's all ad living but that's like more
fun for me i get stressed out more when
i have like oh i have to cover this
point that point that point and like i
like doing it but that's more stressful
yeah this is not stressful i actually
like look for look forward to doing this
one because i never feel like oh my god
we're gonna be sitting there not saying
anything i'm like when does that ever
happen it doesn't happen that way never
no and we always have too much material
we always have like weight and even when
we don't have anything to talk about
like on friday nights we end up like
jabbing our jaws for like three or four
hours so what's i don't worry about that
at all
now um
there's still a place of course for
movies and series you know there's still
a place for all that
so that will still be around but
streaming and casting and youtubers and
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] podcasters have
taken a huge chunk of the market away
from [ __ ]
hollywood hollywood old school studios
they're just steady pumping out crap
and not getting a lot of return for it
they really only make money on [ __ ]
huge blockbusters
and well like i said it's two different
things it's like it kind of depends on
what i'm in the mood for sometimes i'm
in the mood for
watching a movie or watching a series or
something like that or sometimes i just
want to watch somebody that's like
hanging out but we're decorating their
mantle for halloween or whatever i
didn't say it wasn't good i was just
saying that there's still a place for
it's just that they gotta really be
careful because they can't make
a studio can't make [ __ ] 40 movies a
year anymore they'll lose their ass
you know
because nobody'll see them
i mean you know there were good movies
like like that movie that we saw even
indie flicks you know
they come and go so fast nobody sees
them even though they're good
well a lot of times they don't get a
wide release you're right you know
because it's like oh well everyone's
gonna see like the marvel movies or
whatever but it's like they don't really
or it's like sometimes they'll get like
a theatrical release but it'll be like a
week and then it's gone
yeah and then you just gotta look at
stuff like
cable television
like i don't understand how
a channel like hallmark can stay in
business
do you know they still make like a [ __ ]
ton of money dude i just don't
understand i was watching i was reading
an article about it probably like a few
months ago and they were talking about
how many movies they pump out like for
that channel a year
and they do once for holidays mostly
christmas that's kind of their big thing
but they do like other holidays and
stuff as well and like people are still
watching that [ __ ]
i don't know anybody who watches that
well i don't know either but it's like
it's just we're not the demographic yeah
i couldn't tell you a single per i
wouldn't be able to recognize a single
person that works on that channel the
only times that i
hear about lifetime movies is from
nicktoramio's channel yeah who
he will go in there like he'll pick
movies he does a lot of like those
really terrible like christian movies
like on pure flicks but he also does
like a lot of really like cheesy holiday
movies like on lifetime and like [ __ ]
like that and he'll like do
like really long like [ __ ] hilarious
like breakdown if you've never seen like
nick derami's channel oh my god he's
like so [ __ ] he's like the funniest dude
on youtube seriously and he just like
goes and his videos are long they're
like 45 minutes an hour they're almost
as long as the movies that he's talking
about
and he just goes and he puts up two a
week i think
but he does a lot of lifetime movies he
does like some of those weird ass like
kids movies from the 90s like he does
all kind of like crazy [ __ ] but
that's the only time that i see like
lifetime ones is when he talks to them
people are saying it's old ladies and
very stupid young stupid girls they're
watching hallmark okay i guess it must
be yeah but like i said they're still
like very successful they're still like
making they're pumping out lots of
movies where are they i was shocked when
i read it where are they watching this
on tv or well you can stream it well
like i said everybody nowadays because
even like cable television no well even
the regular channels like that you can
watch on tv every single channel yeah
you can watch it on peacock or
slang or they're newbie or i'm moving
into digital platforms no they have done
that they have been doing that well like
i said because there was a time when
there was a division between what was on
cable oh not anymore that it hasn't been
like that for a long time well like i
said you go well a couple apps we have
like we have peacock okay um and you can
go on there and there's
you can either stuff on demand obviously
like tv and movies and stuff like that
but there's live tv too okay so you can
just go over there and like watch all
the [ __ ] live and honestly like even
[ __ ] like um it's not p or uh it's not
peacock it's not 2b it's what that's
what the [ __ ] is that other one that i
have but there's like another one
i can't remember what the name of it is
right now but they even have like a
whole they have a whole rifftrax channel
they have old mystery science theater
channel and it's live tv you just go on
and you just like and it plays and it
plays and there's commercials and [ __ ]
it's just like a regular channel that's
understandable though because it's
coming through
an online app
i thought that they were
hooking up the cable box no no turning
their internet off and going to
television maybe old people are still
doing that that's what i thought was
happening old people are still doing
that because that was like what the [ __ ]
you know no i haven't one you can i mean
and some you know some of the um like
gordon ramsay's shows like when he does
a new show yeah he does a new show live
and then the next day it's on hulu okay
so you just go on hulu and watch it like
with commercials so that's where they're
getting their money yeah okay
that's what i mean nobody is just like i
mean other than me i thought they were
turning [ __ ] down and going yeah looking
box and then go and going every single
thing everything is digital now there's
no such thing as right so you just go i
can't believe like you didn't because
it's been like that for like years and
years right you go to some like i said
sling or peacock or something like that
and it's just like they have like a you
go up in the top and it says on demand
and then you can pick what you want but
then there's like live tv and there's
like a zillion million channels just to
get internet
you're gonna get all those cable
channels all right they just come with
it
so but i never switch over to it
now i'm just i'm actually running
everything through my [ __ ]
xbox one because i got apps on that and
i can go to anything
2b or
uh you know yeah like i said we even got
the damn british channel now so i could
watch all the old box yeah brick
dollars
box
yeah
so yeah we have a link in but a lot of
people do like i said you can do roku
you can do uh the fire stick you can do
all that kind of stuff but yeah we have
the xbox so we have like i said we have
amazon prime we have shutter we have
hulu we have
uh and some of the free ones like
peacock um
2b is free which i can't remember what
the name of that other [ __ ] other one
is man what the [ __ ] is that another one
grantor said that lonely women love
hallmark movies like a drunk irishman
loves jesus okay i got you
oh god
all right because i saw some of that
[ __ ] i was like who the [ __ ] is watching
this they were making us watch that [ __ ]
at the [ __ ] va hospital i was waiting
for him to get my eyes examined
and [ __ ] looking there all these
little vets and they got us [ __ ]
watching the hallmark channel like why
the [ __ ] have we got this thing on and
it says where the hell is the damn
remote and it's like an old wise man in
the corner says they took the remote
[Laughter]
i said they make us watch yeah they make
us watch this and we're in the waiting
room and [ __ ] other guys because they
don't want to make us mad they're afraid
we're going to kill somebody dude that's
what it is they can put calm [ __ ] on
[ __ ] yeah
but the thing about it is like if you
seriously you don't because i don't like
those lifetime movements
yeah
honestly why don't you put on something
that's like more
neutral like you can put on something
like
cooking shows or you know what i mean
like like the guy fieri show or gordon
ramsey so let's everybody likes that
they were trying to [ __ ] everybody
likes that
uh john says are you working through
classic doctor here on brick box
actually i'm working through it
um for the second or third or fifth
sixth time since my childhood because
they used to play all those
on our pbs here i [ __ ] before you
cancel that subscription i need to go in
there and poke around and see like if
there's [ __ ] i want to watch so i'm
gonna watch all the old tom baker once
starting off with robot and [ __ ]
there was a lot of [ __ ] man that that
series was way ahead of its [ __ ] time
the very first episode had
tom baker
and uh you know it's tom baker doctor
who he's already with
sarah jane smith i think
she sees his transformation and every
everything
i think yeah
anyway
he's fighting this secret society down
in britain
of these nazi-like dudes
who are going to take over the world
because they got this uh
superior intellect and they're all
scientists
and
they're going to build a robot that's
helping them do it
and it's and it's this big old ai robot
it's a cool looking retro robot that
they're making
and i'm going who who are these dudes
and they're finally unveiled to be
technocrats
they were a [ __ ] the technocratic party
i was like hell yeah they called that
[ __ ] right
they were going to use high technology
and everything to take over because
democracy couldn't work because people
were too stupid so they were going to
[ __ ] fool people into thinking
democracy was working but they would rig
all the [ __ ] machines to make to give
them all the power and that they could
be a super class and i was like man they
must have been reading bilderberg
[ __ ]
pilderberger [ __ ] and what's in the
club of rome documents and [ __ ] that aj
was [ __ ] looking at but no i was like
damn pretty relevant
and then uh no that whole that whole
retro
if y'all have not seen the old doctor
who
they had tom baker in it they're [ __ ]
masterpieces man they're [ __ ] great
the brits knew how to the writing is
good real good
you know they'll reboot [ __ ] you know
like frankenstein is space
uh
they [ __ ] had just they'll reboot
kind of like
jack the ripper
that was a good one
it was not start your original star trek
did that to you yeah they did that too
except it wasn't jack the ripper it was
cause it was a in in their long you know
there might be six parts to it
the one that was kind of like jack the
river was called the talons of wang
chang
and it's like in old england
1800's yeah
these women aren't uh turning up
disappearing
around this theater
and working at the theater is there's a
chinese magician
and he's got all these uh chinese guys
with him and the doctor gets involved
he's helping scotland scotland yard
and figure out where these girls are
disappearing to
turns out
first of all the ventriloquist dummy can
get up and walk around and tries to kill
people
and you're like whoa what the [ __ ] he's
got a chinese ventriloquist dummy
they did some like movies from the 50s
where that yeah or 40s actually right it
was a 40s the doctor [ __ ] destroys
that thing and finds out that it was a
homunculus that's what he called it and
he said it was from the 1980s not the
18th but the 1980s
and remember all this all those
homunculus homunculi we had in the 1980s
i remember that yeah
but what he said was he called it a
monklis it was a product you could buy
and uh
it was a robot that had a pig brain in
it
and
that this one had been [ __ ] specially
made to be an assassin
and it turns out that
the chinese guys
were just a front they had a damn time
traveler from the 1980s an amer a
dude from earth
used a special technology to transport
himself backwards in time to escape war
current war crimes tribunal because he
was involved in world war three
and he goes back to [ __ ] ancient
ancient china
and starts his own cult like [ __ ]
warrior cult type thing that protected
him and he was like several hundred
years old he was keeping himself alive
by sucking energy out of young girls and
keeping his cells rejuvenated like a
vampire yeah he was doing it with [ __ ]
for with technology from the 1980s
it's a good one though also he brought
back like some duran duran records and
changed things
his name was that was a side plot his
name
his name
was magnus greel and he was kind of like
[ __ ] darth vader but he's wearing
like a chinese robe with a leather
[ __ ] face mask
and it was before star wars
star wars was a british movie for you
[ __ ] that don't understand it man
that [ __ ] was made there they did all
the work he just put something yeah i
mean the entire crew on it yeah
right
granthar says uh johnny depp kept
referring to her turds as grumpy's is
that a common word for a [ __ ] in a bed
he called him grumpy's not that i've
ever heard wait who has words for turds
[ __ ] johnny depp's fake ass would do
that [ __ ] that's crazy yeah um
sly says uh is talking about ask a
mortician yeah i actually really really
like that channel um if you've never
seen that it's this uh young woman she's
kind of like a gothy looking woman and
she's a mortician
and she has like a really really popular
youtube channel where she asks where she
answers like people's questions about
dead bodies and stuff like that it's
actually like really entertaining
uh yeah i got like really behind
i didn't know tom baker [ __ ] married
uh uh romana too the second romana i
didn't realize his wife see that yeah
yeah
both of the romanos were cute
tammy says i for one have never been
bored during any of your live streams
okay john says the towns of wang chang
was a spin-off to an audio adventure
series called django and lightfoot jaggo
and lightfoot yeah that's right those
two got those two characters were in
there jaguar and lightfoot were in there
they were kind of like um
they were kind of like um
investigators weren't they they were
kind of like uh
what was in there
they were kind of yeah i guess you could
say they were kind of like sherlock
holmes and watson kind of
but i just i just thought it was a
i thought it was a jack the ripper
spin-off
danny rowling said hallmark movies are
filled with uh [ __ ] list actors yeah a
lot of them are kind of like um actors
that you recognize like from oh it's
like oh i remember that [ __ ]
from like some sitcom back in the 80s or
something like that so it's kind of like
i hate to call them like husbands that
seems yeah you know they're just trying
to like get work just like the rest of
us but yeah it is kind of a lot of those
things mr 88 said that all criterion
collection
dvds and blu-rays are 50 off
all july barnes and nobles oh [ __ ] maybe
we should go there's the barnes and
noble in the mall where our movie
theater is it might be online jesus and
then he goes the criterion released
entire lone wolf and cub which tom
recommended on a previous episode that's
right yeah
the cub series was good japanese and we
have it it's beautiful yeah yeah it's
like coming from tokugawa it looks like
tokugawa era japan and all these like an
old-fashioned paper and something i mean
the artwork is gorgeous it's really good
and it's like this big box and it like
all that was the that was the original
uh mandalorian basically it was
basically the mandalorian was a ripoff
of lone wolf and cub well i mean i don't
know if i'd say ripoff because they
absolutely said
you know this is like a star wars
version of lone wolf
so you know what i mean they did
acknowledge uh that that was where they
got the idea from i mean but yeah it's
the same story if you didn't know
uh john smith said my favorite doctor
was when i grew up with sylvester mccoy
i don't remember which one that was i
never you know here dude the blonde
curly hair guy
there have been so many yeah i liked tom
baker that's my favorite yeah it's like
i honestly
i watched it when i was a kid because i
had a cousin that was two or three years
older than me and he was like really
into it and so sometimes we would watch
it was on pbs like back in the 70s and
early 80s
and then i kind of like lost track of it
for a while and then
i didn't really watch it again until i
think christopher eccleston was on it
because i really you know i really like
it he was a good doctor i really like
christopher eccleston well i've seen him
in like tons of stuff he was in
i don't know if you guys have seen this
but he was in a movie that was um an
adaptation of the thomas hardy novel
jude the obscure and it's just called
jude
which is i love that novel but it's
probably the most depressing novel ever
well i don't know if it's the most
depressing novel ever written that'd
probably be the road by cormac mccarthy
but it's pretty depressing
but still it's still like amazing
so they made a movie out of it and it
was him and kate winslet and i [ __ ]
loved that movie and i never hear
anybody talking about it for whatever
reason for me
the doctor's tom baker or tom baker is a
doctor in in the same way that in this
in the same way that william shatner is
captain kirk you know
although
the second [ __ ] captain kirk
done by old [ __ ] what's his name
from star trek continues he's good too
uh what's his name dick
what's that vic yeah vic mignon
vic mignon and todd haberkorn does spock
on on
star trek continues those are really
good
if you like that original star trek the
old you if you like the original star
trek they wrap that [ __ ] series up
and and connect it to the star trek
motion picture and they give star trek a
final c season and it's all a lot of the
same riders and the same guys that were
in the old one
and it's it's
this
it's got the same tone and everything
you watch star trek continues you can
see it for free on youtube
in hd
and it'll take you back man and [ __ ]
when that series ends [ __ ] kind of
oscillating he said the same thing in
the final [ __ ] episodes as it's
ending you get your lump in the throat
and everything but i cried you're like
oh man i right right because there's a
lot of [ __ ] you didn't think about
like
why did spock leave service why'd they
have to go to vulcan to go get him to go
[ __ ] intercept veger it was a bunch
of [ __ ] that
it's in that
they wrapped it up
it's good
but the writing is excellent a lot of
the same writers
that's why they had to shut vip down cbs
shut that [ __ ] down
because uh
his that was a fan series but his fan
series was better than
[ __ ] star trek
the cbs star trek that they have now
it's a lot better
what was it
std
star trek discovery yeah
john smith says tom baker is an
interesting guy but in his autobiography
he dedicates exactly one sentence to his
second wife lala ward yeah yeah she
married uh richard dawkins later did she
not yeah
they might she'll be married she was the
cute blonde right with the big tall
forehead
the big toe yeah she had her hairline
was way up on the top her head
parted in the middle but she was cute
little pug nose
blonde
pug nose and a big tall forehead yeah
if you said if you saw pictures ever you
know exactly what's talking about well
i've seen her before i know who she is
but like i said i think i think she was
married to richard dawkins she might
still be or you know i don't know if
she's still alive she's cute
but were there two romanas though
because that he said ramona too i think
i think they were i think there might
have been two of them yeah
i don't like yeah like i said i kept i
saw the old ones and then like i saw
some of the newer ones like on and off
but i didn't really like follow it all
the way through see you tom knight
dom yeah throw us in
you said tom that's that's your name say
good night
tom
i thought you were saying good night to
yourself no
oh man speaking of william shatner
we found a show on
it's on hulu right yeah because we
finished watching
the food that built america which is an
excellent series by the way that was
fascinating every single episode was
like almost an hour
and they went into all the kind of
man it was really really good
so after that we got recommended a show
i guess it was from 2019 i want to say
and william shatner's on it and it's
called the unexplained but without an e
in it so it's u n x p l and you know so
it was like that and he's on everyone
like talking about they do like a bunch
of different stories on everyone but
they're kind of like themed like there's
like here's one that's like
creepy areas like the suicide forest in
japan and blah blah blah and then there
was one that was all about cryptids and
they were talking about like chupacabra
and the goat man and all that kind of
stuff
and
there was one then we watched one about
like unnatural nature that had stuff
well like uh centralia like pennsylvania
and what else was on that one
uh i can't remember now but yeah that
was just kind of like but that's kind of
like fun too but the funny thing about
it is that william shatner
who's got to be like in his 90s like on
the show he still looks good though one
you can tell he's probably wearing a
girdle or a corset or something like
when he comes out and they do the long
shots because he's kind of coming out
like looking like
i was like yeah i know that walk so so
he comes out doing that i've done it
myself many times
um but he's kind of coming out doing
that but
they have like all of these interview
like interviews with people talking
about whatever the topic is and then
he'll come back in and be like
a man that's half man and half goat
crazy you know what i mean it's just
like really funny how like over the top
he is it's a super fun show though i'm
like i'm enjoying it but
we just got had that recommended like
after the food show that we watched but
yeah it's on hulu i don't know what show
was what channel it was on to start with
uh fun shatner fact says john smith he
was in the only movie that was filmed in
esperanto yeah that's right and i can't
remember what the name of the movie was
but i remember hearing about that like
it was kind of like a big deal at the
time remember you know
you kids today like you maybe won't
understand but
when
when did the whole esperanto thing start
i kind of feel like it was early 70s but
it may have been before that
esperanto was supposed to be
wasn't it they they kind of like posited
as like a universal language right
language yeah they were trying to like
get a language that like oh everybody
should learn it and it's just kind of
like a universal it was kind of like
taking bits from everything i don't
really know but it was a latin base it
didn't really go anywhere though but i
just remember it being like kind of a
big thing for a minute
english took over
basically especially with the internet
because we're the ones making all the
movies and well i think internet had a
lot to do with it for a while there was
a for a while there if you wanted to be
on the internet you better speak english
now you got other countries that have
the apps in their own language and
but
in the 90s
if you wanted to be on the internet you
better you better know english because
most of it was in english
john smith says i i'd like shatner's
song you're going to die playing at my
funeral
i was talking about the william shatner
show we've been watching yeah it's
pretty good it is pretty good i mean a
lot of it is if you know anything about
weird [ __ ] or paranormal [ __ ] or
anything like that like a lot of it's
not going to be new information
to you
um
but it's got like nice
i kind of feel like it has like nice uh
production quality like it looks like
it's a high quality like i was watching
the one about cryptids last night and
they had like the lady on there that
found the chupacabra and all that but
they were talking about like mothman and
i was like the mothman like animation
and so i'm like wow that's really nice
i really liked the mod the mothman
animation says that his parents were
gonna [ __ ] send him to esperanto
school yes i was
that's right when i was a little kid in
the 70s
the international language was french
yeah not even english it was french
well i feel like english and french are
the two official languages of the un
right or they were when i was i don't
know about that in the 70s
not even english it was just french
and um like most your scientific
journals and everything were all in
french
and which is one of the reasons why when
you saw close encounters of the third
kind you know what i mean the guy in
charge of that [ __ ] was french he's
remember that he's speaking french and
yeah he's in charge of mufon basically
but um that kind of gave it some more
gravitas i remember when i was a kid
that was like oh man hey speaking french
yeah he knows what's up
that's an international language
i took french in high school
for four years
i don't remember much about it though
because i didn't like use it a lot right
but every now and then if i watch a
movie that's in french i'm just kind of
like hey i know what that means like
without the subtitles you know
uh they're talking about masterpiece
theater
i remember some of those
i remember some of those not a lot of
them i don't remember any of them like
specifically but yeah i remember like
watching that sometimes back in the 70s
and 80s yeah sly says he listened to old
art bell shows to put him to sleep yeah
they're good
our belt
our bell he was the [ __ ] master man
he had a [ __ ] great voice
and he could
take something that was just
not much and turn it into something real
mysterious like and today we're going to
talk about i can't even do his voice you
know
the pit to the pit to hell
today will be
and he he has
in a hole in his backyard that goes to
hell and he's recorded voices of the
demons
[Music]
that was that was that was uh what was
great about art
art never really made fun of any of his
guests or any of the subjects
you could tell he
you could tell when he kind of didn't
believe it
but he left it up to you yeah
he asked pretty good questions but he
was never real
he's trying to remain diplomatic yeah
right yeah i don't think i'd be able to
yeah he'd remain diplomatic
i'm not good at like just if i think
you're full of [ __ ] like it's gonna even
if i'm pretending to like to be nice
it's gonna come out
when you had to get a radio and you had
to dial in on it just right to listen to
it [ __ ] it was kind of an adventurous
time where's the radio i gotta see if i
can find our bellies come with our belt
yeah you were listening to it i always
felt like art bell like whenever i
listen to that i always i always
imagined like some trucker like in in
his semi
driving along like route 66 or something
listen to art bell yeah then it was like
a ufo
that's what i always imagined
it has a very like desert like
southwestern kind of like vibe too well
he made sure that because he was
broadcasting out from the desert that's
what i'm saying so it's just like it
always like had that vibe to it yeah
like i'm driving out in the middle of
nowhere
like on this road and like there's
nobody else around and maybe there's a
ufo and like hovering in yeah it was
pre-internet early days of the internet
and radio was still
a real powerful underground means of
communication and getting information
and
i remember you know
listening to arbel talk about stuff like
the mueller sky car
and i'd get on [ __ ] 90s internet
and try to get pictures of this thing
and it's like damn
so radio was as mysterious and powerful
as
early internet for a while
then when you looked at them up on the
internet you'd have to like wait for the
photo to like photobeat forever line
yeah
four hours later
[Laughter]
yeah
remember those days yeah man i would not
want to go back to that it's like you
did some [ __ ] though
you gotta like walk away and go do some
other [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna go do the
laundry and mow the lawn and then i'll
come back and maybe the one photo will
upload
got some real important information here
got it downloaded from the internet
oh really yeah it's got to be big you
know you're looking at it oh yeah
it's just uh there's another time
although you know what it was a romantic
time it it was a time where you could
still believe in crazy [ __ ]
you know although the craziest crazy
[ __ ] still happens people still believe
in crazy yeah yeah
well they're no crazy [ __ ] still happens
it's just
now it's there's not as much mystery
like we know every inch of the earth
there's no way you're going to [ __ ]
find an uncharted island
like back in the novels you know oh my
god it's atlantis
dinosaurs on it nobody knows about this
island you know everyone's like that'll
never happen come on
you know although there will still be
people that believe it or there might be
something up on the uh down in
antarctica the [ __ ] frozen
pyramid
i saw what they were talking about i was
hearing people talk about that a long
time ago
that satellites have found a [ __ ]
pyramid
on antarctica
what is it just like a snow hill
and went back and looked at what we were
talking about yeah it's like it's it's a
frozen mountain that looks kind of like
a pyramid
that's what i think but it's the snow
drifts and it's also the angle of photo
and the with shadows is on it you know
sidonia stuff like cedonio i mean it's
cool and everything but it's just kind
of i don't like like to piss in anyone's
corn flakes but
come on
there's there's enough like cool [ __ ] in
the world that's actually real like you
don't have to like make up stuff
our bell would get up there that he'd
have a whole guest you know it would go
on for hours and hours a whole against
not happening a whole guest
a whole guest behind him
and would talk about that one photo for
[ __ ] an hour and a half you know
kind of like that that's pretty good
like the face on mars and sedona and
richard c holgwood hoagland hoagland
that's just hoagland
and if you look right here are you see
this see the shadow and you see look see
on the side of this mountain what we
have here
is a garage door
because you don't say it opens up and of
course this is right in front of the
grand temple right here and the landing
strips and look there's a dodge dart in
here
and if you see right here and here and
here this all connects into a line which
we see that you can see plainly see
the only thing that looks like this on
earth is power lines
and these are the
these are the remnants of ancient power
lines
you know power poles
i feel like if you say something with
enough conviction there's gonna be like
a percentage of people that are gonna
believe it even though like if you think
about it for five seconds you're like
wait a minute that's [ __ ] come on
oh richard c was the [ __ ] though he'll
[ __ ] keep you going the the
photographs weren't good enough
to go your face yeah after they got good
ones they're just gonna like oh yeah
that guy doesn't look like anything he's
probably still got that game if he's
still alive though he's just changed it
if you well that's kind of what they
that's what you have to do and we were
kind of talking about this a little bit
when we were you know a wednesday show
when we were talking about like the
spiritualists and stuff like that
when somebody like
debunks your [ __ ]
you gotta come at it from like a
different angle because you still gotta
like keep that grip going you know
well you see
in those days you know what i mean the
photos weren't that good they were like
high altitude side of satellite photos
but now you have those rovers
so now you got to change the game to
smaller scale yeah if you look right
here next to this other rock you can
plainly see it says marlboro
this is the top of a pack of cigarettes
yeah
next dimension media says hey jenny and
tom have you covered the skinwalker
ranch in utah yeah yeah we did a show
about that i don't remember when it was
but
it was probably like a couple years back
i feel like we did that was bigelow's
place
i don't know his name bigelow i don't
remember what his name was but yeah i'm
pretty sure we did a show about that
louis says hey there's people that
believe the earth is flat yeah they do i
mean
i think in this day and age
i kind of feel like probably 99 of those
people are trolling yeah but
there are some people out there that
believe some really really stupid [ __ ]
so it wouldn't shock me
if
there was
maybe a couple percentages of that our
friend julie believed in that our friend
angel she's a god chick she's she's our
age she's my age she's not she's older
than jay
she's into all that she's into
conspiracy stuff she's into the [ __ ]
flat earth [ __ ] but she's [ __ ]
trolling all right
she said that
she said that satellites were actually
held up by helium
you know satellites yeah there's a
helium yeah i know what a satellite is
that's a helium balloon helium balloons
yeah
she's like
i said it is not flat
you know
and she and i says how do you how do you
explain
that [ __ ]
that the [ __ ]
that they that the sun goes down and
comes out on the other side you know i
mean you [ __ ] had the motion of the
sun
and she said it's actually a flat
surface and the sun is doing this over
it it's like in a circle that's what
they used to say it's like a donut
shaped flat earth
so in other words earth is a donut it's
like a donut and it's flat and see
here's the thing
you got to cut black flips to make that
model black flips yeah yeah
to make that model work
when the simple solution is that it's a
sphere
spinning
but oh that's too easy you know we
that's too easy
you gotta [ __ ] make it flat you gotta
make
theories that [ __ ] caused this to
work
if it was flat and so then they have
these weird
twisted torpordial [ __ ] flat
earth and they don't call it a flat
earth
phenom they don't call it flat earth
well they have to probably give it like
a scientific name earth truth
[Music]
i was gonna say you really know they're
[ __ ] trolling you know i was gonna
say i thought they'd have to give it
like a more scientific because you know
how the creationists
like they got like back in the day they
got like they're like yeah the your
shit's religion you can't like teach
that in science class and they're like
no no uh it's scientific now we're
calling it intelligent design and then
they were coming up with like all of
these
dis proofs of like evolution which were
all [ __ ] if you looked at them but
it's just kind of like
man
i don't know like victor says conspiracy
theories are like a mental disorder
these days yeah i agree well the thing
about it is that
you know and i'm not saying that smaller
scale conspiracies don't exist but like
people that think that there's these
like world-spanning conspiracies and
it's just kind of like oh the earth is
flat and everybody's like pulling it's
just like come on now come on do you
know how many people would have to be in
on that
to like [ __ ] it there's just no way
there's no way well there's no way a lot
of the world the thing about well no
what i'm saying about like the thing
about people that believe in conspiracy
theories they genuinely believe in like
really crazy like big ones
the thing about that
i think
they're not as
they're not as smart as they think they
are
and they think that oh well if you
believe in like the scientific consensus
or whatever um that's what everyone else
believes or that's what like so i'm
gonna be like even more intelligent than
that so i'm gonna doubt that
it makes them feel smarter i think is is
what the
appeal of it is
that's jenny's theory
my theory of of what she's talking about
is religion
okay
it's a battle of will with religions
most of the [ __ ]
crazy conspiracy theories have to do
with dinosaurs and earth being round or
flat
okay
i think a lot of what they're doing
is they're just coming up with a way to
go no
no no no no i'm right
that's all it is
well that's what i'm saying
they're saying they're saying that
they're smarter
than people who have actually like
studied the [ __ ] for years and years and
years even though they just like sit at
their in their house and watch youtube
all day if they actually believe what
they're saying i don't really think that
they do believe it
some of them do though yeah yeah i'm
sure some of them do i mean there was a
dude saying they either do or they waste
a lot of their [ __ ] life energy
like pretending they do which i don't
really understand the point of that the
reason why you would lie and this is all
old there aren't very many people that
still do this
so talking about it's kind of funny it
makes us feel like boomers talking about
it most of the people that were really
serious about this are long dead
uh
that was like my grandparents generation
they were really fighting hard on a lot
of that stuff they're all dead
they had [ __ ] out
you know shit's wrong when they're
trying to say no
dinosaurs had those sharp teeth but
they're vegetarian because
bats have those same sharp teeth and
they just eat fruit
why would they say this why do they they
want to say that they're the dinosaurs
are not old
why is it they want to say that
dinosaurs are not old because of the
bible they
no that's you know here's the thing the
bible doesn't say any of that [ __ ] i
know they have interpreted the book of
genesis
to mean that the earth is only six
thousand years old yeah nothing it
doesn't say anywhere in
genesis that well earth is six thousand
the six thousand years old that comes
from the dude like in the 1800s who was
doing some exactly they made up the
[ __ ]
six thousand year old so they came to
that conclusion then they had the back
date right right you have to fit
everything in right
and and it wasn't and now
in the media here in the united states
they made sure
to kind of tarnish all christians with
this
when even when this was going on
all christians didn't believe that it
was just some of them and they were the
most
pain-in-the-ass ones okay
most christians didn't believe that
there were a lot of other christians
throughout history that believed in
evolution it's just that you don't hear
about it
no it's i don't think that's enough they
didn't tarnish all christians with that
i mean
i knew they tried them as far as i knew
everything i saw for like the media and
like i said i've been an atheist for a
long time right uh old earth
creationists are very small percentage
there's just a small percentage of them
right um there are other creationists
that are um
you know what do they call it the the
creationists that believe the earth is
6000 years old you also have
creationists that believe that the earth
is as old as it is but that the bible
when they say it's this many days of
creation they mean x million years or
whatever so they're willing to say yeah
the earth is as old as science says it
is we just still think god created it
which whatever fine um but then there
are a lot of christians too that think
oh well evolution is true but god
directed it just like i said fine
that was most of them young earth
creationists what is that what were they
called i remember i don't remember what
they were they're just called regular
christians uh honestly like young earth
creationists are a very very small
but they were very small but vocal
minority no there was
i'm gonna find it i'll talk about it on
another show
that
there was a certain kind of christian
they had a name for him
or a term to describe him and most
christians fell into the the the
description of that term
is that that they believed that the
forces of evolution were the will of god
yeah well like i said that was the
majority opinion it's the majority as
long as i've ever remembered right and
and here's the thing
the dude darwin was not the first one to
come up with this [ __ ] he was the first
one to kind of codify it and really
write big books on it
they had guys
in the 1700s
that were
religious
kind of christians but they were
scientists
and knew about animal breeding and
started to think that
nature was breeding animals into being
other things and other species
that
nature was kind of like the hand of an
animal breeder and that was the
mechanism by which god created creatures
and things that were inanimate
that's kind of like
proto-evolutionary concept well yeah i
mean
the idea was not new it was not a new
idea i mean darwin was the first one to
come up with codified [ __ ] well he was
the first one to come up with like the
mechanism in natural selection but the
idea had been around for a long time as
anybody that worked on a farm or anybody
like that that did animal breeding like
you said yeah um it was very very easy
to notice that you could change an
animal and they didn't know about
anything even darwin didn't know about
genetics well they didn't know they had
the dna molecule yet right but they saw
that it was happening so obviously like
he was just the first person to kind of
like
have a framework for it but it had been
yeah there there were precursors
obviously the modern stereotype is is
that christians and muslims and jews
were not scientific no they were they
were very scientific
it was just later on in the industrial
revolution you had a lot of religious
problems in the united states and
certain religious groups tried to stop
the progress of technology and science
but that didn't represent what
what was
the mainstream of any of those religions
uh
[ __ ] one of the greatest
scientists of all times was [ __ ]
super christian
and crazy isaac newton
invented physics and calculus real
religious
got real into alchemy later into alchemy
too
he's actually fascinating i wouldn't
actually mind it i wouldn't mind doing a
show about him because
i read a book about him
like not about his scientific
discoveries which obviously were amazing
but about kind of his later life where
he was kind of more into alchemy and
like doing like
yeah so it was kind of like way that's
really they were in this they were like
something out of frankenstein novels he
was into science mathematics physics
religion
alchemy and mysticism it was all
there was no reason to differentiate it
back then
we kind of like got into this on the
deal with frankenstein well we kind of
got into this on our uh show about
spiritualism and seances and stuff like
that is that and i said you know i'm
going to give a pass to a lot of
scientists that went to seances and [ __ ]
like that because
back in those days you have to this was
before radio this was before television
this was for electricity um and a lot of
those things work
invisibly yeah so back then people would
have thought it's like magic yeah
because it seems we're i'm sending a
message here and then somebody across
the [ __ ] ocean is getting this
message and there's no wire in between
like there's no mechanism by which we're
communicating and that might have like
seemed like magic so it's not crazy to
extrapolate from that hey we can talk to
dead people like beyond the veil like i
said it's not a crazy thing so i kind of
understand like why a lot of scientists
were into hey i'm going to like thomas
edison hey i'm going to build a phone to
talk to dead people or whatever like
tesla did that all that kind of stuff
like i said it wasn't crazy back then
because the possibilities were still
open like nowadays everybody's pretty
sure you can't do that but
back then they didn't know so and
throughout history man
human beings are super fascinating
and ancients to me were more fascinating
than modern people in many ways the
ancient greeks the romans
the mayans all the mesoamericans
the mexicans or the meshika
i mean these dudes
would sacrifice people they'd flay
people alive they'd do all these bloody
things
but they thought it was for good they're
trying to repay the blood debt
to keep the machine work of the [ __ ]
universe moving forward
and they're [ __ ] geniuses these guys
all right
they're they've come up with some of the
most advanced
calendars
far more advanced than our calendars
more accurate
they're basically
time worshipers the keeper of time
they're trying to keep because of their
religious beliefs they're trying to keep
time
flowing forward
because their stories basically told
them that it was their duty
you know and then they better not [ __ ]
it up bro they're gonna get in trouble
you gotta pay back the blood debt to the
[ __ ] son that created you
and he's the one that's causing [ __ ]
time to move forward it's just fantastic
calculations that could only be done
through this advanced calendar
and they're beautiful to look at
and a language totally based
on emojis basically and combining emojis
and we've only recently went the western
world has understood what an emoji is we
were trying to figure out what kind of
[ __ ] language is this it's [ __ ]
emojis
that's what they are
if there's really no difference yes
and then they're combining and squishing
emojis and to mean something and then
changing the facial expression to give
an emoticon with the emoji and then on
to the next one
just
it's a vast it's an advanced thinking
and dominican friars
we're trying to write back
to the
to the pope saying no we shouldn't burn
all this this is a [ __ ]
a huge library
of [ __ ] advanced knowledge and
they're being ordered to burn it because
of the work of the devil yeah but the
guys on the ground are like nah
we really shouldn't do it but eventually
they did it yeah they did and the only
thing that came back was like the
dresden codex and [ __ ] a few codexes
were saved
some of the the same this the central
wands but
lost civilizational stuff and then if
you looked at what egypt was doing and
you looked at what the mesoamericans
were doing man
i got to give it to the mesoamericans
with the whole emoji thing and the
calendar thing
yeah the egyptians can make a badass
structures
but
the meshika and the the mayans were more
mental gymnasts more mental gymnastics
they were i think
you have to have a greater imagination
you know to come up with what those guys
came up with
well i'm always i i admire a lot of the
people from the past because it's just
kind of like think that they didn't have
a lot of the shortcuts and like the
you know the ease of things nowadays are
trying to figure it out on their own
they're just trying to like figure [ __ ]
out they didn't really have any other
resources except for their own like
[ __ ] brains and the [ __ ] that they
figured out is like mind-blowing
john smith says uh leonardo da vinci
wrote about finding shells in the middle
of italy yeah uh suspected an ocean was
probably there a long time ago and said
the planet was probably a lot older than
people suspected yeah and that was like
in the 1400s
i remember i think stephen j gould wrote
um an essay about that if i'm
remembering because i used to read like
a lot of his books of essays and stuff
and i kind of feel like he wrote
at least one essay on that or maybe
several because i know he had he had
like a bunch of books that were
collections of essays and i think he
wrote one about that how leonardo
leonardo da vinci like figured out
you know he wasn't just kind of like hey
what are these
shelf like fossil shells doing at the
top of this mountain he was like oh this
must have been the bottom of an ocean so
like i said they weren't
you know so maybe like the earth is like
really old
they weren't dumb back then they figured
some [ __ ] out
um
yeah victor says where's tila honestly
like yeah tila hasn't been here
in a little while it's like i hope she's
okay i know they moved i think they
moved but i don't know she's like on a
different schedule now or she doesn't
ever
yeah i haven't heard from her in a while
it's like it's crazy
um
let's see
yeah camp guy says shell fossils inside
caves in central tennessee 1000 feet
elevation yeah i mean
that's the thing it's
it's something to think because humans
lifespans in the uh you know in the
grand scheme of things are
very short you know less less than a
century
and so
it's easy for us to be like oh well this
is like a mountain now or this is a cave
now but
it's always going to be like that but
it's not always like that and sometimes
it's like in only a thousand years like
i said and it's like completely
different
which is crazy but yeah leonardo da
vinci even figured that [ __ ] out yeah
victor comes where's teal at i don't
know where tila's at she's cheating on
me
she's cheating on us
let you do it i gotta haven't seen her
in a while
she jumped in how long ago was that
about a month ago it's probably like a
month ago now
she's looking good in that [ __ ] about a
month ago yeah i'm gonna guess i'm at
about a month ago she jumped in
and uh
she said hey
and i think they were getting ready to
move
something was going on
but she hadn't been in for weeks and she
jumped in for a few minutes and then
left
go yeah cos that's a good point of view
thank you i didn't know if you were
listening calm
yeah man the batoon that's some heavy
[ __ ]
you see nowadays we only have days weeks
months years maybe a century or
millennium they didn't have any ideas
about batum okay
and
there are some
cgi representations on how
the mayan calendar which is the same one
the mashika used the mesoamericans all
basically used the same calendar they
might have put different emojis in it
and had slightly different stories about
it but basically the same kind of system
and it was a bunch of spinning
wheels
all interlocking like gears
and um they could break things down they
were the masters of time
they understood time a lot better than
westerners of that time did
and uh big into the stars how stars
moved
and uh what's funny as far as we know no
mechanical clocks
but they knew about days and how to
break a day down
how to [ __ ]
they're worried about 10 000 year and
100 000 year cycles i mean they were
[ __ ] deep into the [ __ ]
and they're
dealing with very big numbers
but they don't have the arabic numeral
system they don't even have the
the roman numeral system which was also
unwieldy they had their own number
system it was dots lines
and the way the lines would go
and
we don't have a lot of uh
examples of their mathematics because a
lot of [ __ ] got burned but they to deal
with
the numbers they're dealing with when it
comes to time they had to have had
pretty advanced mathematics
you know whether or not they were
applying it to engineering probably not
uh
mesoamerican engineering was
good but
simple um
they weren't
making huge stone blocks and assembling
pyramids they would just make a mountain
pyramid shaped and or and start building
on top of it and then and then a king
would change and he built another thing
on top of it was just like
what they call a superfist superficial
what do you call it a
facade it was facades over mountains and
then they would dig into there
because um
mesoamerican city-states just didn't
have the population of say actually
egypt they were they were didn't have as
many people in them
they're agricultural their skill wasn't
that good
um they couldn't they would deplete the
land
around the city and the
yields would start diminishing and they
thought they were being punished so
they'd
start
increasing sacrifices
and trade routes in between the
city-states wasn't very good because
there weren't any
wheels
and the roads weren't
paved like say in rome so no a wheeled
car wouldn't help them you know
so each city state was like its own
kingdom trying to survive now they did
make little empires like the mexicans
made an empire
out of the other city-states
they had them paying trib blood tribute
to pay back the blood debt
which is that's what a dominant culture
does
um now it's kind of totalitarian
if you disobey will sacrifice your
daughter it's your religious duty and
they all believed in the same religion
these were not
alien religions they all basically
believed the same thing
so a lot of people willingly went up
to those
sacrificial altars on the tops of those
temples to be executed or have their
hearts cut out so they could go to
heaven man i can't believe i thought
well i can't imagine believing anything
that strongly on faith that you would go
up there and have your heart torn out
yeah going to heaven
your time to go
you believe you were created
by by god
and that the blood and your the blood in
your body was borrowed
so it had to go back because you're
starving other people of the prospect of
life
so this is all for good things this is
all altruism
and we believe it's crazy [ __ ] like that
too you know
altruism always is
well let's put it this way
the feelings of altruism are always used
by the ruling class for their own power
dynamics
i make you feel
good about your sacrifice to me to keep
me in power i can only do it through
stories
we do it today
yeah
now i will say though that altruism is
a natural human phenomenon because other
like apes and stuff like that have it as
well they also have like
yeah they also like apes also have a
sense of fairness yeah uh so it didn't
come from nowhere like other animals
have it too
but
yeah it can absolutely be used uh yeah
you used a very part of your power john
smith said not was aliens
it's more fun to think it was aliens
it's more fun i don't know to me it's
just kind of like
one i don't know like i'm not saying
that i don't think that aliens exist i'm
sure they probably do
but the whole like you know grays with
the big heads and the big eyes and stuff
that are coming here and anal probing
people that to me is like not super
interesting
i don't know why because a lot of them
seem a lot of the stories seem to be
like kind of the same i don't even like
horror movies where like it turns out to
be aliens i'm like oh
you know what i mean it's just kind of
that i don't know why it's just like not
really all that interesting even though
i do think they're probably really
aliens but i don't think they look like
the [ __ ] that you see in movies though
and i always thought and i always kind
of got mad
because i was kind of like with that
whole [ __ ] where people think um you
know the aliens built like the pyramids
and all that kind of crap i was like
dude
uh they weren't stupid back then they
they figured it out they didn't need
aliens to do that
it's like it seems like really insulting
i'm offended on their behalf khan's in
there trying to get me to talk about
piccolo
yeah
but call was lord piccolo or lord shield
or great shield was it that's the
translation of his name
and he was one of the
mayan city-state rulers they found his
tomb they got they got
that's the the cover of his tomb you had
to get dig down to get into it the cover
of it is that famous
petroglyph
of what people
claim as a man flying a rocket into
space
yeah that's right that that was the
stuff i think i read an article about
that was the cover of lord piccol's yeah
sarcophagus
that's not what that is though
everything can everything in that glyph
can be explained in religious terms
of the of the mesoamerican people what
it is it's the king
entering into the afterlife he's being
launched into the spirit world
[Laughter]
all the stuff's there
and he's seeing he's seeing the gods as
he's going that's what it is
sending you a heaven on a bottle yeah
you're going to heaven going to heaven
in a damn rock he's gonna put you in
like the t-shirt cannon like they have
it like [ __ ] baseball games [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's hilarious colin's trying to get
me to brag about his people
[Laughter]
we were walking on the moon the
americans were walking on the moon but
well not we but like well i'm just
saying america we were doing i didn't
walk on the boat i don't remember that
but
back in the day the 1300s 1400s even
maybe further than that
the mexican people were walking
underground in the cenotes
deep miles 10 20 miles down is most of
us filled with water now
underground
caves filled with water
but some of them aren't filled with
water yet and you'll find dudes
four or five of them dead leaned up
against the wall
with [ __ ] torches in their equipment
an expedition that went way down in
there man 20 miles into those caves
in total darkness with torches
like hey we wondered where these
[ __ ] went to and they went down
there
to place somebody in somebody in death
in there into the into the underworld
for some reason or another when they
were talking about shaboba the
underworld they're the mexican hell
there's a physical place they went to
those caves
that's some wild [ __ ] i don't have
enough balls to [ __ ]
walk 20 miles into those caves [ __ ]
basically all sandals
yeah and light clothing and i like cases
and torches and flint
and hey don't let the fire go out
you don't know we're [ __ ] and that's
what happened to those guys the fire
went out and there's no way to come out
that's like
that's big [ __ ] man that would be harder
than going to the moon back in those
days
that would be the equivalent of a moon
[ __ ] shot
and what are they doing
they got a dead dude with him on a
stretcher
they're trying to place him into a real
good burial spot deep in chavova
let's go jorge yeah let's go
he must have been important you know
that are very dangerous
it's like we're probably trying to even
get a [ __ ] deep into hell god damn it
yeah
john smith says after the descent [ __ ]
caves and everything in here yeah that
movie yeah and like i said i like caves
but
yeah that movie was kind of like
that was super claustrophobic think of
how brave you had to be to do that in an
era when you believed in demons and
monsters and you quite you weren't quite
sure what a cave was i mean they've just
been [ __ ] a brick yeah because for
them a cave in hell was the same
thing okay
so you're physically going to go into
hell
with this dead dude tammy says well
aren't they actually your people also
tom because you're an honorary mexican
that's right i forgot yeah it kind of
kind of convinced me thomas is
yeah yeah i wonder how far that's
getting at
the cost pretty white
you don't want me to say
that because you know he's like no man i
don't have any spanish blood in me and
i'm looking at him and going i don't
know
your sons all look like johnny depp to
me
yeah kind of no lie
no lie either
kanavatsan's got two sons in their 20s
that look like johnny depp they look
like hollywood stars
he was last night he got [ __ ] drunk
was sending me videos out in his [ __ ]
parents backyard
and they got he's down it's not really a
yard it's kind of like in brazil it's uh
just a stone in the inside of a big
swimming pool
with all his good-looking relatives and
they had a mariachi band in there
nice yeah and they're eating barbecued
were they playing morrissey songs they
should have been playing morrissey
[Laughter]
and he's sending me videos himself and
he [ __ ] pans over look at him and
he's loaded with a damn beard and says
he's like yeah
don't drink social media you guys yeah
okay look what he said he said yeah tom
is a white chicken that's what i was
trying to do
yeah
it's true of course it's true
come on let me show them your house your
parents house khan
well don't like showers like people
don't because some people are weird
about that
yeah kind of watson said good times
eating people and plundering yeah yeah
those were the days
okay those were the days there's kahn's
house there's kahn's parents house
man that's it wow yeah it's really nice
it's a mexican paradise
hold on that's really good i'm trying
maybe we can move to mexico i heard it's
like really cheap to live there
right
see he got the band there and everything
with his sister-in-law
why did you come here yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know if you guys know but yeah
there's a whole um
subculture
of
mexican
smiths and morrissey cover bands
they [ __ ] love that [ __ ] down there
there's con and some of them are
actually really good kanavasa
getting his drink on
oh my god yeah
everybody's wishing me happy birthday
yeah i mean it is your birthday man you
should like if we go to mannequin if you
go to mannequins tonight
we just shouldn't have to pay
yeah that's right i should be free
i mean i'll pay but you don't have to
pay
although i did buy you lunch and a cake
yeah you bought it
today
see what everybody's doing
that's like [ __ ] funny
fly says the egyptians believed they
would live after death and they did
when we yeah yeah when you dug them up
you go damn
i mean yeah i mean people still know man
you can go to the [ __ ] med in new
york and all their shit's like right
there so you know
right that's like a nice backyard that's
a nice pool oh yeah yeah it's nice
that's kind of like like uh
kind of like the places i used to live
in brazil
i was telling them about that man it
looks just like sao paulo brazil
everybody's everybody's going yeah come
on
yeah it's a beautiful pool tammy
i've always kind of wanted a house in
the pool but then again i kind of don't
like i just want money to keep up with
that's what i'm saying i just i want to
enjoy it but i don't want to like and
you see we'd have to maintain it we'd
have to build it i mean we have lots
in the yard but
i don't know like at our old
neighborhood
um the you know the whole neighborhood
had a pool so you could go over like
some of the houses had their own pools
too but like you could go over there and
i only used it like a few times because
i was like they'll be like children and
they're gross but
you know um so i always kind of wanted
my own but then i was just kind of like
well i kind of don't because then i'd
have to like
take care of it and i'm like i'm too
lazy to do that kind of stuff
i'm not lazy in some ways but it's like
that kind of stuff
like if i had my druthers like i would
rather like live somewhere with no lawn
no bushes no nothing because it's like i
don't want to go outside and like mow a
lawn and like trim hedges [ __ ] that
jesus christ
i would rather just have nothing i'd
rather just zombie rocks and stuff
picture says until the victorians ate
them and then they were dead again right
they they found so many [ __ ] mummies
back then they were just like [ __ ]
mummies they were tripping over the [ __ ]
and it's like
yeah they ate them they burned them for
fuel
they were just laying around they didn't
really like think that
it was that big a deal
so
uh yeah kind of awesome said yeah it's
expensive we built out in 87.
is it cheap to live down there
i've kind of thought about
i don't know i don't know if i'd want to
i don't know if i'd want to live in
mexico or
maybe be nice to live somewhere cheap
you know
i mean up here it's okay but it's kind
of expensive just saying i was watching
this video the other day of like
places like um
places that were like easiest
to
emigrate to
like countries and mexico was one of
them and there was kind of like a lot i
think belize was on there
uh there were a couple others like
central american countries i think
brazil was on there too matter of fact
um and then there were like some
european was like sweden denmark i think
was on there like just that they're not
talking about they weren't talking
necessarily about um how expensive it
was to live because sweden and denmark
are a little bit expensive but they were
talking how easy it was like to live
there you know or to move there if you
were an american like they didn't you
didn't have to like jump all through
through all these hoops and everything
like that
victor says i want to retire in santiago
chile
all right what's i don't know if tom's
been there
i'll have to ask him because i know like
when he lived in brazil i know he's been
to
i think he's been to chile i don't know
if he's been to santiago though
yeah kind of offensive for americans is
very cheap
maybe maybe someday
although i'd really like to live
somewhere cold i'm just i'm tired of
living in a hot i'm tired of being hot
mexico would not be as humid as florida
it's not as hot i mean temperatures can
get high but i don't think you have a
hundred percent i mean i guess it's a
massive country so i guess it would like
depend on where it was yeah and uh
certain places got real good air flow
whereas the [ __ ] breeze a lot some of
it's drier more desert up north
have you been to uh to santiago
santiago chile yeah yeah okay because
victor said uh that he wanted to retire
sanchez was
beautiful when i was there in the 80s as
a kid
it's a city of copper
everything is [ __ ] copper and it
never rains
high altitude it never rains there if
you spin on the ground it'll be there
forever they made like laws about that
they made a lot of laws about that
you can't yeah you gotta keep it quiet
gotta keep everything clean nothing
washes away
um high altitude
and um
cocao leaves were legal you people were
[ __ ] drinking cocoa leaves and
[ __ ] snorting cocaine to get
acclimated to the high
altitude
now i don't know if you could
it may not be that way anymore but
cocaine is illegal
yeah is it still
yeah cocaine is like a [ __ ] taboo
subject here in in the us but
in
south america
with the exception of brazil
most south american countries don't care
and it's not worth much
that's what i'm saying i thought it was
technically still legal or at least
decriminalized yeah well they don't have
a big craving for it
you know what i mean
well like i said it's just kind of like
in europe because well not so much the
uk but other parts of europe where it's
like you know they drink wine and [ __ ]
like that like when they're younger so
it's not like ooh i'm being all like
[ __ ] rebellious by like drinking and
stuff like nobody cares that much about
it it's kind of considered to be
medicine there
and uh yeah people will snort it but i
don't really think that they're addicted
to it or if they are i mean
so what a little bit of it was like five
cents victor said it's super modern now
santiago santiago santiago yeah
i also was in uh uruguay
montevideo
i think it was that was either uruguay
or paraguay i think that was uruguay
and i've been to paraguay also i
remember where it was
but i went to uruguay and paraguay
um never went to argentina
but
um never went to peru
there's not much there though
i think they have some ruins there that
people like to see adriana says jenny
moved to scotland
i've never been to scotland i've been in
england and wales but i didn't i wanted
to go to scotland but i never got up
there
adriana also says as a latin american uh
buenos aires looks beautiful although
the inflation in argentina wouldn't uh
make it as friendly to live in
and victor says montevideo looks nice
too
yeah i mean you know there's good food
all throughout just looking for like
options you know okay like for some
cheap ass [ __ ] in case i gotta like go
move somewhere cheap you know what i'm
saying
yeah montevideo is uh uruguay
yeah uruguay yeah
paraguay is uh ascension yeah yeah i
don't remember where i was it wasn't one
of the bigger cities yeah victor said i
just rendered my passport so i can get
the [ __ ] out of here at least for a
little while
i probably need to yeah i wonder how old
mine is i renewed it a while back but i
don't remember how many years ago that
was because they're good for 10 years i
think once you get to the south of
brazil
and below
you're basically back in europe
you do have
what you would call indigenous or indian
type people but they don't look anything
they don't look very different from
european people
at least nowadays some do but most of
them don't
on average you know they look like
people from chile
kind of
chile uruguay montevideo
uruguay paraguay argentina they all kind
of look like that
they're good-looking people
tend to be kind of dark-haired
dark eyes
fair-skinned a lot of them range into
medium-type skin
um
you just
you know they have what you would call
genetic diversity so they could look
like anybody but you go there and
everybody looks familiar in brazil i
blended right in a lot of people didn't
believe that i was american they thought
i was putting on an accent and
everything you know no
so you know in brazil so you know
there's a lot there was a lot of german
and irish immigration into the south so
you have a lot of mick henry's and
mcduals and mcdowell's and
in in argentina and uruguay and chile
you got irish people there you got
germans in there you got a lot of
spanish names mostly spanish names
but it's just
it's a mix kind of like the united
states although if you go south less out
less african go north a little bit more
african
because they did have africans moving
into places like brazil
not anywhere else though brazil was a
place where there was a lot of
early on during when they had slavery
that was a place where you would send
them because there was just a lot of
agriculture there the rest of the the
rest of the country back on the the rest
of this continent back on those days
there wasn't really a whole lot going on
there it was pretty sparsely sparsely
um populated they didn't need labor
you know
john smith says move to albania dirt
cheap will take anyone and all the coke
you can snort allegedly yeah
i'm sold
john smith uh is talking about um huge
german population in brazil for
reasons yeah we also yeah okay it wasn't
just
it wasn't just the war they were there
before
they were there before the war too yeah
but that's why everybody knows that's
why you know it but they were they were
there before the war they went there
after the war because there were already
germans there as part of it
yeah i was trying to think of like the
other
one of the countries they mentioned on
there was ireland and i was like i
didn't realize because like i said this
wasn't necessarily a video about
where is like the cheapest to live it
was where's the easiest for an american
like how many like you don't have to
jump through as many hoops
like to emigrate there you know what i
mean yeah so they were talking about so
a lot of them were central and south
american like i said belize there were a
couple of other uh mexico a couple other
places there um
but there were some european ones too
and i think ireland was on there and i
think canada was on there too even
though i've heard that it's a pain in
the ass like to move to canada yeah well
i mean it's
oh one place that i saw that was like
they said was super easy to move to was
mauritius
which they said basically all you need
to do to move there is put five thousand
dollars in a
bank account like in the country and
then they'll and fill out a form and
they'll let you in
which is crazy
that's crazy i don't know there's like
videos like that like come up in my feed
and i'm like oh that's interesting so
it's like i was just like curious to see
because i remember like you know because
i was um
married to a british person for a while
and he like came over here on a tourist
visa
and then so after we got married i had
to go through the whole like immigration
process and it was a massive pain in the
ass
and
it takes over and we didn't even have
like the worst of it because and
honestly we even had somebody at what
was then called the ins um
tell us well it's much easier for you
guys because he's white and he speaks
english like had he not been white and
not spoken english this would have been
a lot more difficult and even then
it was a massive pain in the ass and he
even had to be here for two years um on
like you have to like have a provisional
some countries have five years u.s at
least back then had two years you had to
be here like uh with a green card for
two years
and you could have a job and [ __ ] but
you couldn't vote or you can like do
anything like that
and then if you wanted to apply for
citizenship you could
but yeah it was a big
big pain in the ass you had to like go
and get like all kind of uncomfortable
questions like i asked you you had to
fill out like 40 bajillion
forms you had to like pay like
i don't even remember how much it was it
was a lot of money all right john smith
asks a good question we read that right
there to the end
two questions right there john and
connor bossland's questions are good
john smith said i used to date a german
brazilian and she was more german than
anyone who met from the fatherland that
was the one thing she was more german
than in german yeah
oh yeah one of the most german places in
in brazil was a [ __ ] place called
gramato
and it's in the south it's in
it's a little bit
it's not i don't know if it's in what i
would call the south i remember i think
it was it was south it was south of sao
paulo i've been there they they have a
tourist trap there they fantastic
chocolate
um but there's a german region down
there
the uh
they were isolated
okay they didn't really integrate into
brazilian society at large
and they uh
the population kind of just intermarried
with each other
now whatever so it's kind of like a
german colony
now i've heard recently that they all
left
that they got sick of that and that they
just
went to the united states or went into
brazil and that
they don't really do that anymore
but definitely the ones the
the world war ii veterans and their
children which have been the boomers
they stayed in there but gen x and
everything they all left
so they may not be there anymore
now um
khan asked about did hitler go to
argentina or did he kill himself what do
you think
yeah
i've looked at all those stories
there were a couple of them that really
sound convincing that that [ __ ]
mustache man went to argentina
i'm gonna call it mustache man
but there's no concrete evidence
okay
knowing the totality totality of
mushroom mustache man in his situation
and what was going on inside of germany
in the final weeks
and what kind of guy he was i think it's
more likely he killed himself
i think it is a lot more likely and the
reason why i'm saying this is because
mustache man was sick
all right
he uh
the mustache man you see [ __ ] giving
the speeches and the ones that the
germans knew
and then the mustache man that [ __ ]
in the final weeks of the war were
totally different guy it they said he
looked like he aged 50 years
he was pretty broken
his uh
uh what do you call it
his um
not tourette's syndrome what do you call
it when your hand shakes
um parkinson's his parkinson's had
gotten real bad
he had a doctor named dr morrell who was
just a quack
who was a syphilis doctor which makes
most people think that
mustache man would have
had tertiary or [ __ ] laces
yeah i kind of feel like he probably i
mean i thought that was kind of yeah
most people probably thought that oh
syphilis which makes you very
rigid in your thinking if you make a
decision you won't ever back off of it
it can make you kind of
robotic kind of lizard-like
and uh
will kind of give you weird feelings of
[ __ ] being a little bit like out of
body because your brain isn't working
that well
so to treat him for that
basically what they did was is they kept
him jacked up on methamphetamine from
the minute he woke up they injected him
with meth
then he couldn't sleep
so they'd knock him out with morphine
so he was a bad junkie
in the final
days
those drugs kept him [ __ ] constipated
so he was blowing up they said he had
real bad gas
and he was a vegetarian and
having real problems with his bowels so
he was just a farting machine machine
he didn't feel good
um
this all started really when he lost all
those men on the eastern front during
the battle for the battle for stalingrad
he asked he asked gory should i bring
him back because we probably can't
really supply him out there can you
supply him during the winter he goes oh
yeah i can supply him during the winter
but no the planes all got shot down
and like about a million men died out
there and he never really
psychologically recovered
then they hit him with all the drugs
and then all the drug thing all the
drugs and
was the beginning of you know the final
solution to the germ to the jewish
question
that's
that phase happened
during that same phase
you started having germans
in the in in the mustache man party
start jumping ship and starting to run
in the final months
too you know a lot of that damage that
he did
uh was in the final 12 months the last
year
especially the very last six months
that's when a lot of the [ __ ] really
weird [ __ ] happened
he was [ __ ] losing it
drugs
now
in his mind
there's no way he could allow himself to
be captured by the russians
he was gonna he was gonna go down and
take germany with him and all the
germans that believed in him went with
him used most of them
okay
in the final weeks you had ss dudes
running around killing german civilians
that were surrendering that's what kind
of place he was ordering people to go
out and blow up all the aqueducts and
all the [ __ ] water pure
purification plants all the power plants
there wasn't going to be a germany after
him he was taking everything with him
like it wasn't bad enough he was like a
lunatic before but then yeah like it
just he went way off the rails
he was he was he was [ __ ]
weird
but when you looked at the rest of the
party he was the moderate
out of that party earnest rome was worse
they were they all they were all pretty
bad they also he was he was the the
moderate one
out of what was there
um
so
i always hear these people well if we
kill this dude you know then we'll
they'll be free you know like we [ __ ]
kill putin and they'll be free a lot of
times that's the these are the moderates
the problem though yeah yeah
one person
it's a whole system of they always have
like backups yeah because there's as as
crazy as like one person and it's like a
figurehead and i can understand like
there's like hey this guy is our problem
like i understand that but
he also has people that believe his
[ __ ]
and
if you kill him then
in a case of mustache man it wasn't his
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was already there
he joined it
he didn't invent that party he was a
member
the other members in there
some of them were worse like rome was
worse
but then during the night of the long
knives he killed rome and all his
support all of his supporters off
so it's different
factions in there vying for power
and they got rid of hitler at that phase
late in the war they would have
surrendered because probably who would
have taken over probably would have been
goring and then goring would have
surrendered
probably i don't think hedrick
i don't think i think ryan i don't think
reinhardt heydrich he was really the
main one when you think of the
stereotypical mustache man of the bent
cross and all those [ __ ]
you know war crimes and [ __ ] like that
it was reinhardt hedrick and also known
as hedrick the hangman
he was the main one all right the rest
of those dudes that were under hitler
were kind of just
functionaries and guys of not real
it wasn't really much to them there just
could have been anybody just suits
really you know
but hedrick reinhardt hedrick he's he
was full on you know that dude was a uh
he was a [ __ ] stone cold killer he
probably would have replaced hitler he'd
been worse
he'd been worse because he was smarter
than hitler and a lot more competent and
the people were scared of him
okay they were real scared of him
and he was a lot younger
younger smarter
a lot more ruthless
so you got to be careful with
assassinations
you assassinate one another
yeah it's never just one person it's
like always
you know i'm not saying that like one
person doesn't deserve to get
assassinated i'm not saying that but
it's like they always have like some
people like that believe in their [ __ ]
and like back them up yeah and it's like
what happens if that if they get taken
out then there's like a power vacuum and
then like you said some worse
[ __ ] that was a supporter of
them might like yeah
might get brought in there so it's like
you might be even in even a worse
position than you were when you started
yeah well
the whole support and mustache man
wouldn't have made a difference
because the problem was a mustache man
the problem was nazis
okay that's what it was it was an idea
these are our problems it was it was an
it was an ideology yeah and mustache man
probably believed it one of the the less
the least actually he didn't really
believe it it was just um it was just a
way of getting in there and getting
power and doing stuff
because there's a lot of stuff recorded
to him kind of making fun of certain
things that that that the nazis believed
in like he didn't believe in the
anti-derby he thought that was [ __ ]
they he they were using a lot of
propaganda
but a guy like reinhard hedrick he
believed it
you know what i mean
it's like you gotta watch yeah it was
like a religion that's another thing you
don't know like what [ __ ] is
actually gonna believe that and like
take it too it's like logical extreme
another thing that people
people think that this is because of the
form of government what was fascism or
it was this and that it was that it was
nazis were common as nah
nah it didn't have anything to do with
the of government it had to do with the
dudes that were in control that that's
the main thing
like
communism [ __ ] did a lot of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] mao was the worst one but there
were communist governments like in
czechoslovakia that were pretty good
because the dudes in charge were we're
sane
and we're actually trying to help the
people
other people like stalin's were just
trying to kill enemies
so it always boils down not to the form
of government but who's in charge
because it doesn't matter the form of
government because
whoever's in charge breaks the rules of
the government that they command anyway
so well they're just kind of
doing what they want they're doing what
they want to do so it's like if that
person is like a horrible person then
yeah you're gonna have a bad time if
that person's like an okay decent person
then you'd be a little bit better then
it'll be fine now the form of government
is like a safeguard well which one of
these [ __ ] in charge if he
follows this form of government or keep
him in check that's the american system
all right other forms of government are
just
and even the american system i would
question it it's mostly just
a facade mostly it's most of it is
oligarchy you know
you have to have some kind of legal
system to keep rulers in check
most countries don't have it i would say
probably right now [ __ ] 95 percent of
it countries don't have it most rulers
just do what they want
they make the law obey what they want to
do
the laws are for you not them
the form of government is for you not
them and that's that's i think that's
been true that's basically what it is
right yeah
right
let me go to the restaurant
so valkyrie was based in real events
yeah oh yeah yeah that was a real thing
yeah they tried they tried to
assassinate him yeah that was i mean
it's uh i remember the movie was kind of
uh dramatized but yeah that that's based
on uh real stuff that happened
um
worse after that assassin failed
assassination he got worse he killed a
bunch of people became more ruthless
more paranoid he doubled down
it'd been better just to defeat the
system
not so much go after a particular guy
yeah because sometimes yeah because the
thing about going after an individual
person like i said it's never especially
in a situation like that it's never just
one person it's always just kind of like
a network
of people that have these like [ __ ] up
beliefs and it's like so if you take one
out like i said you cut one head off
it's just gonna grow another one like a
[ __ ] you know chimera hydra or
whatever the [ __ ] so it's like that's
gonna happen
so
they have they always have a support
system they always have people that
believe in the same like [ __ ] that
they believe so
taking out one person as satisfying as
that might be um is probably not going
to help you and actually might end up
being worse in the long run
i mean no talent it did you but i'm just
saying like largely i just don't think
it's a good idea because you never know
what's gonna happen like after that
danny rowling says the most german place
in brazil is that village that joseph
mengele carried out his twin experiments
and to this day there's a bunch of twins
running around that village supposedly
hmm
i'm kind of interested in that i've been
wanting to do a show like i think
somebody suggested it like a long time
ago that we do a show about
we've done a nazis in the occult show
but i wanted to do one that was like
nazis in south america like that what
kind of thing because that's like a
really interesting story but i put it
like in the patreon poll a couple times
but it never wins so there you go
um
john smith's uh has
signed off he's like gone to bed so if
you're still here uh good night
victor says yeah you're not really
freeing them the people support them
until everything starts going to [ __ ]
yeah and the thing too is that
even like the worst
[ __ ]
people uh have supporters
mind-bogglingly
and
i think too i think there's something of
like the sunk cost fallacy like if you
supported somebody when they were just
like marginally shitty
and then they just got shittier and
shittier and shittier and then like
until it was just kind of like this
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] show
and then like you had to justify like
your support of them so you have to keep
doubling down and doubling down like
digging your heels in so i kind of feel
because you don't want to admit
that you were stupid or you were wrong
or something like that i think that's
a big part of like human psychology
once you've gotten so into look i've
supported this guy for two years or four
years or six years or whatever the hell
it is and it's like and then you turn
then it turns out that this person is
a dumpster fire even though like most
normal people saw that like a long time
ago but now that you're just like
clueing into that um you don't want
everybody thinking you're an idiot for
like supporting them all this time so
it's just kind of like okay well so it
in a lot of ways you kind of have to
double down it's a very very common like
psychological thing that people do but
unfortunately but yeah people do do that
uh let's see
oh well thank you
oh but i was gonna finally come down and
answer khan
the psychology of mustache man
is that he couldn't be captured
and to be
to be seen
running
he was very honor-based
and because he was so sick
he knew he knew it's only a matter of
time he's he ordered basically ordered
the destruction of of
of germany and the german people
and then he killed himself i'd been like
[ __ ] hey i'm here too you're right no
right
well
what the [ __ ] gives you the right his
friend albert spear betrayed him by that
time he says man how are you giving
these orders up yeah get the [ __ ] over
yourself you you tiny there's gonna be a
germany after the war and he's like no
yeah sorry and [ __ ] spear was like i
gotta go
and he's like get out
it's like that's millions of people yeah
many of which do not agree with you
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
you're [ __ ] he just didn't want to be
uh
i can't take it he was kind of uh
lizard-like and not flexible and he's
like the russians have now
are now in control of the country and
this is going to be russia and they're
not germans anymore wipe them out they
failed me
that's what he said they failed me
what a [ __ ] yeah
i'm glad he's dead he was partly right
half of it did kind of become like
russia east germany
the other half kind of became well for a
time for a while but it wasn't permanent
but you know as far as his mustache man
was concerned he didn't have much he
knew he was he knew he was dying so he
was like [ __ ] it i failed they failed he
he he [ __ ] threw the ultimate
temper tantrum you know i'm going home
you'll be like like little cartman you
know i'm going home that's it that's
exactly what i think of
like where
i don't okay
no
adam of my being
do i understand a person
a single person on this earth of however
many billion people seven eight billion
people now
why do you think that your stupid ass is
so important that you can like wipe out
like i i i'm gonna answer the question
why oh well you you know of course i
know because
they uh they had the problem of the uh
they had they had the problems with the
vinemar republic germany [ __ ] was in
total chaos it got extremely poor his
party got in there oh yeah i know
i know about that they pledged an
allegiance to him
that's where all that [ __ ] started
the the here's the thing this was not
politics these this is not a form of
government this is a religion
it's it's more like i'm also not a fan
of it's more like a religion so you're
talking about it almost like a jim jones
type situation again that's what you're
talking about not a fan and so they had
pledged their allegiances to him he was
their savior they had all the trappings
of religion and he by he he's buying
into this
you know he's trying to save germany
fatherland and he's also in the cult so
it's exactly what it was but a lot of
countries are like that a lot of
communism was like that in certain ways
for a while and
it was just
japan was like imperial japan was like
that worshipping of god emperor and
uh you know sacrificing your life for
the motherland it was just it was a
thing of the time like i said that's
still kind of around
it is well you know humans are the same
i mean you know so they're still but
honestly like just me i don't know if
it's just me but it's like i've never
that's why i never got the appeal of
cults i never got the appeal of anything
like that i'm like i don't want some
[ __ ] telling me what to do piss
off
you don't know me germany japan and to a
certain extent kind of like russia
we're civilization states in other words
the state or the government itself was
was an ancient civilization or
considered itself to be an anxious it
was a kind of like ancient egypt
the country
the population and its leadership were
all considered to be manifestations of
the same thing kind of like an ant
colony
so
when the ant colonies was defeated you
know what i mean it just it
imploded there wasn't it was
totalitarianism and it was collective
well let's say oh individuality i
understand that right it's just like
from my point of view to me you're an
individualist i was just kind of like
you're an individualist and in those
civilizations did not provoke promote
individualism as you know it that's a
western concept they weren't really
western
not really
like i said i don't like anybody
whether i know them or whether i don't
know
them telling me what to do
all collectivism is dangerous
all of it
it's going to turn human beings into an
ant colony and when the ruler is not
pleased he destroys the colony that kind
of [ __ ] happens just wait which like i
said where the [ __ ] do you get off
oh i'm going to kill like millions of
people you're not going to don't even
[ __ ] know you're the queen bee get
the [ __ ] over yourself seriously get the
[ __ ] out of here mentality
actually i say that but that's good
advice for everybody every human on
earth please get the [ __ ] over yourself
yeah you're not that special yeah
just like the second that you kind of
think hey i'm gonna wipe out a whole
city or a whole thing
because of some temper tantrum that i
had just yeah check yourself just check
yourself you're not that special
you're just like he goes wow this sounds
so familiar yes it does sound familiar
doesn't it
there are any qual qualitative
differences they're mostly kind of
quantitative differences well like i
said it's it's a human psychology right
right like i said um i understand it i
don't have that but i understand
i understand it though
but i think i don't have it because i'm
just kind of like really cranky and i
don't like other people generally so
that might that might you know what time
it is right it's almost time to shed it
oh my god it's like quarter to nine we
talked the night away it looks like
[ __ ] everybody's been with us and had
a good time
and we've been talking about mustache
man and all kinds of [ __ ] but look
i got to get out here got a silver up
something we got to go in a bit of dance
gotta go somebody said we need to review
the movie rain of fire
um which one was that that was the
dragon one right
i don't remember that i remember that
being pretty good i think i saw it back
in the old days i don't remember when it
came out but
maybe we'll get around to it one of
these days
i promise
dragon axe okay
tammy says respect my authority yeah
yeah
that's essentially what i think of every
time
some [ __ ] comes in and she's
like well i'm gonna like kill all these
people
that's like exactly what i see i didn't
think of carpet i'm like oh are you
taking your ball and going home all
right yeah yeah get the [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] over yourself please thank you very
much victor thank you victor happy
birthday tom i'll try to make the show
more often i mean i mean i know you have
to work and stuff like that it's like we
don't expect like people to show up but
yeah so
uh sunday
okay we're gonna do like a movie rev on
sunday i don't know what movie we're
gonna do yet because we'll have to watch
something tomorrow now sunday night
we're probably going out too because
yeah got another goth night we got
momentum oreo sunday night because it's
like a holiday
but we will be here doing a movie review
i just don't know what it is yet but
thank you everybody for dropping by
thank you for all the super chats thank
you for selling freddie celebrating
tom's birthday with us
and we're gonna
lay here and sober up for a little bit
and then we're gonna go out to
mannequins i can drive and go
i could drive i could drive home
he didn't even have his license lisa but
yeah sorry that was word science um so
anyway
i just like randomly quote some john
hughes movies but yeah so we'll be back
on sunday reviewing a movie thank you
everybody for dropping by
have a good weekend until we see you
again
and good
night